this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised everybody welcome to the Sun
sets Safari here in room in the sabi
sands that was a southern black suit and
my name is Steve joined by Craig on
camera and what a marvelous afternoon it
is it's it's not too hot it's about 28
degrees Celsius about 86 degrees
Fahrenheit I think I might have got that
completely wrong but anyway it is a
wonderful day and what Craig and I are
going to do this often is we're gonna go
and see if we can find any more tracks
or sign of that lioness that was in the
drainage just around the corner here we
were forced to abandon the search this
morning due to the fact that there were
too many elephants on site so we just
can have a little look around it's going
to be quite difficult to do but let's
see what we can find
don't forget we are live where
interactive and we'd love to hear from
you on hashtag safari live or just throw
your questions in on the YouTube chat
stream that is the southern exits many
people will confuse it for a fork-tailed
ronger it's got a much narrower tail and
it's got a very different call folks are
longer there's also got a little bit of
more of a rounded body and if you could
tell have a very red eye but easily
confused by most people but a very very
common bird our chap and Paulie is able
to do a very good mimic of it I am NOT
you can also see the beak is a little
bit more sort of slender and he is on
the top of his perch shouting to all the
world that he owns this patch but the
forks held Rangga like the southern
black flycatcher or both in fact
flycatchers who sit on the end of
branches like that and practice an
insect catching strategy of hulking like
bee-eaters they will fly off of their
perch catch insects and land there once
again the forks are longer being one of
the smartest of the fly catches in that
they actually will follow around large
mammals to get them to tour all sorts of
animals in fact to get them to disturb
or provide the food for them I've never
seen southern black fly catcher
having the same way as a Forks l-drago
that's not to say that they don't do
that but anyway I am not the only one
artists after noon
Taylor mccurdy is also out on safari
she's just around the corner for me and
she would like to say good day
good afternoon everybody hello hi there
how's that whatever way you prefer to be
greeted my name is Taylor and I'm camera
with me today is that though and we are
also driving around at the sabi sand
just like Steve but we're not looking
for lions we are going to try and follow
up on salamba from this morning so we're
basically hitting along the fire break
right now guy remain is on the right
hand side but I thought I'd spare you
all the terrible view and we're gonna
basically head straight towards Ned Wood
Road and the Malati we did stop briefly
though at weavers nice Pangolin track
because he heard of Franklin's sort of
choking away and well not sure it wasn't
shaping was an unhappy truth but sort of
alarming and it was perched up in a tree
and there was an Impala standing dead
still for like five minutes nobody was
moving we couldn't work out what was
going on so we just watched and we
listened to the intervention II the
Franklin flew out of the tree I couldn't
see any Raptors around maybe it was a
small cats or something maybe like a
African Wildcat that was just hiding
away in the bushes that most certainly
wouldn't want to be seen by us but
anyways we eventually drove off once the
Franklin started moving around and
started eating we thought well it
couldn't have been that serious so that
was the case no weather claw lumber is
going to be in this spot or not we'll
find out it didn't actually rain at all
and it wasn't too hot so she could have
stayed perched up on that term I would
have a very nice spot for her would have
been very very suitable so let's hope
she's grown in pink and well is actually
spent most of the day sleeping this
we'll check around for some tracks and
just uncertain as to what her we're
sorry her favorite spots are
each ticket let's have a quick look
because she wasn't far she's just on the
other side of the Malati between Edward
and the maratti so she could have turned
back and come this way I mean there's
lots of Egyptian God had to try and
catch
we'll have a quick look at them they
just on the damn wall they're done
swimming for the day just three of them
and they're having the most wonderful
time you can see them waddling along
they're very awkward at this stage
though they're not all they're
funny-looking things they're so weird
and there's also a go away bird that
sounds very unhappy ringing ringing
that's exactly what this sounds like
I'll never be able to end here that you
do realize that Frank is all I hear on
him in Johannesburg as well every
morning it's ridiculous well luckily for
Craig I think most of the team think
about something similar and since I'll
should we just have a quick look as
these Gosling's go down into the water
wonderful so Craig is probably the most
thought of person in camp and all the
Gosling's go
finally Patrick has made it safely to
the Mara with or without his clothes I'm
not too sure let's go and see how he's
doing
hello welcome everybody it is a great to
be back my name is Patrick joining me on
camera is Manu and we're coming to you
live from the Masai Mara here in Kenya
now we have been on the trail of kinky
tail for about the last Oh hour or so
and she has definitely eluded us for the
time being we were following her she was
definitely separated from the pride and
seemed to be either relocating them or
relocating her cubs now for anyone who
doesn't know kinky tail is one of the
more famous members of one of our prides
here the sausage tree pride and she has
just given birth to Cubs not too long
ago so we're not sure whether she was
looking for them looking for the pride
potentially both maybe the prides going
out on a hunt we're not sure but where
she's gone now well we'll keep looking
so she was definitely sniffing out a lot
of sense and kind of going not in any
proper direction she was going this way
and then she's going that way
and then she was going over that way and
then circling back so there was a lot a
lot of indecision from her and thank you
for welcoming me back everyone
what did I do on my leave well I did a
lot I've got a lot of barrows gas or a
lot of friends call up with some some
family I haven't seen for a long time so
that was really great
just did all the things that I'd loved
doing in Australia the one thing I
didn't get to do though was dive my
serve my equipment needed a service I
couldn't really afford that so I didn't
get to dive but I did do a lot of free
diving and a lot of snorkelling so there
was many many fun times to be had and
I'm coming back feeling very refreshed
it was a long hiatus six weeks there was
a bit of a visa being that had to sort
out in Australia before I came back but
all is well that ends well and I didn't
actually mind the extra time off
still scanning around for kinky tail we
are kind of add a bit of a higher level
right now so we are at the advantage and
I want to make the most of it
I'm just gonna do a quick scan with my
by nose and grass grass grass or grass
that's one thing I've definitely know
this since coming back here is that
there is a lot more grass and a lot less
Velda beast when I was here in November
it was the start of the short rains and
there was a bit of a weird kind of
remnant of the migration so there was
still quite a lot of wildebeest quite a
lot of zebra and since then it's
definitely settled down I think I've
seen one wildebeest the whole time of
being here in the Mara well I've only
been here a day but still I suffer a lot
the other time
Noriko a sign of kinky tails still so
I'm going to continue on my hunt and I
believe that Steve down in Juma is also
trying to fight under lioness for
himself welcome back from leave Patrick
I hope you've had a good one and diving
though but I'm sure he got up to all
sorts of other shenanigans
anyway we are in the same sort of boat
as Pat right here we're trying to find a
lioness in grass that's at all of in to
my waist so anyway there were tracks of
a lioness who we believe to be amber
eyes I'm not sure the thoughts are
empires is with Cubs and we think they
might be somewhere here in this drainage
light now just over here is one of the
old high in dens on the other side as
are all this another hyena den this
we're gonna sort of have a little look
around listening sort of feeling our way
around and I wanted getting off the car
not something you want to do walk into
lion cubs with a lioness it's for the
brave for the real brave or should I say
for the stupid ready so here in there is
maybe a lioness with her cubs so we go
to see if we can find it
obviously we need to be very sensitive
and the grass is very thick and very
tall and there were lots of elephants
here this morning that's what caused us
to stop our search in here and also due
to the fact that it's so thick it's not
ideal
we did track her for quite a bit on
reports of here the other day bringing
Cubs across the boundary from the other
side so Kimberly they are indeed elusive
I don't think they trying to be elusive
they just it's just a vegetation and the
mire is that a lot of rain in the grass
is really really tall so Pat's Canova's
work cut out for him up there we've got
our work cut out for us down here as
well but we're gonna see what we can
provide for you this is ideal habitat
for a lioness or a lepidus - Heather
Cubs we remember in the dry season
tracking tndi through here is an
absolute nightmare
absolute nightmare Becky well we'd love
to be able to show you lion cubs in Juma
we really would I mean this morning
hours and walk with Coley and I was
trying to get in to highlight the fact
that the Mara said lion cubs for ages
where you really need to come to the
party because I wouldn't administers
yeah we're two three minutes from camp
you know remember the whole of last year
should have a beginning half of life in
my first six months yeah I was blessed
with princess Columba being around camp
being very well not right back in but
close five minutes away and we spent so
much wonderful time with them and well
our bars is a pretty relaxed female so
if we did find it I think we'd probably
be able to view her cubs quite nicely
but I'm really not sure how old they are
one of the dens is just over here
somewhere it's just a little track that
takes you in
but this drainage is very very tricky
very tricky and can be quite difficult
to navigate we're gonna find
hello Rosalind well generally a lioness
in her first litter only has one or two
not really too many but they can have up
to 6 6 the kind of recorded number but
I've never seen a lioness with fresh
cubs more than four but then in saying
that a pride that I spent a lot of time
with in the Kruger they had enormous
amounts of of youngsters with them
they're all about a year already by the
time I got this I wasn't sure who mum
was but there were 17 Cubs in that pride
so a few of the females had bred at the
same time but 6 is kind of the max that
Alliance can do that three to two three
maybe four or something that happens
we've seen up in the Mara seems to be -
it's the way forward these days we don't
know how many of them are lost right in
the early stages because they're just so
vulnerable those early early stages but
so this is what we're dealing with
everybody thickets around us listening
tracks on the ground we're gonna really
circle this block a few times to see if
there's anything going on and well while
we do that we get to see what's
happening and we'll go back over to
Taylor and see if she's had any luck
relocating on the princess salamba
we're trying to figure out a way Steve
hunt alerts the lumber art because she's
moved from where she was it looks like
she must have been up and down here on
laid wood road because there's a lot of
vehicle tracks stopping and turning and
then turning around again so I'm not
really sure why she's been on what she's
been up to but they only footprints on
the sand just yet also I've made a grave
mistake this afternoon I've worn long
pants I don't know why it was like a
little bit cold throughout the day I
have absolutely no idea why I wore long
pants I'm so uncomfortable right now
I might even have to swing Basque have
been put shorts back on sometimes I'm
not very clever
oh well who's truly earlier now it's
Tristan there is not a chance Kristen's
everything and she suggested that I get
those zip pants never you wear those
depends Kirsten that you can go from
long to short just like that you wear
them wait them not chards since what
would you wear them no sense of the
fashion diva in camp also says our furs
are not hot it's practical how do you
say impractical but you know just not
for everyone I would love to see Kirsten
in a pair of cargo this is a short long
pants whatever you want to call them I
think I would die with laughter it would
be spectacular actually Kirsten I'm
gonna get you a pair in every color or
your birthday that's what I'm gonna do
okay so that's exactly what's gonna
happen and Kirsten says she sometimes
weighs one fence once lake unzipped and
in one point apparently that's the
fashion in Johannesburg now I'm sure it
is
I'm sure that's everybody what
everyone's wearing at the club's I'm so
we won't be doing that will be Safari
chic we will see hi birdies look no
comeback can you still see them since oh
thank goodness
oh content almost flew away but luckily
they decided to just hang tight on that
branch a Hello red-billed hormoz these
are fast becoming some of the most
annoying birds and the reason why I say
that is because they bang on everyone's
windows everyone's windows and they
spend the whole day pecking away at
their reflection it is not not a lot of
fun and it sends oh so great although
they're not too bad it's the
yellow-billed hornbills and the DRC for
like six hours a day i did but i say
that i don't normally get annoyed with
animal sounds I know James doesn't like
the sounds of the boo
I remember how irritated he used to get
Donna saunas camp in the Masai Mara with
all the stylings he used to hate it it
was really funny I didn't mind as the
steep straight through that Sun oh is it
a cuckoo diz land hang on you're gonna
try get you a cuckoo I've been trying to
put an African silcoon on camera since
we got a day 12 o'clock up on that
little the little shrubby behind her
there we go you got its into frame
gotcha gotcha gotcha gotcha there is an
African cuckoo hello I've been seeing
them flying around all the time and they
keep taunting me no answered stove for
me to put them on camera but now finally
we have you all sandals got you I think
it's thinking tonight can't you see me
they're funny-looking birds aren't they
pretty easy to identify though with
those stripes along the braced then I
wanted to check on my mobile device
while you look at that there was a
Madagascan cook I don't have a picture
because it doesn't occur here there's a
Madagascan cookie that's been seen at
the pool Kruger yet I think I mentioned
to you and I couldn't I was trying to
figure out what the difference was
between the two because that quick
glance they look exactly the same man I
guess can transform its have a let's
have a little search also you have to
excuse my my phone because it's got lots
of cracks in it loads and nodes I'm
almost ready one of the differences they
look exactly the same can someone maybe
help me I don't have a bird book okay
you ready sensor let's see there's lots
of cracks
you have to tell me cuz I can't see the
is a glare fine or is it bad fine
no good so that's what a Madagascan
cooker would see all these lots of
cracks here needs time for an upgrade oh
that's gone there its back again so I'm
not sure what the differences are we'll
have to have a closer look but that's
what a Madagascan cookie looks like and
very special to see one in southern
Africa so nice so yeah if you're in the
Kruger National Park I don't know if
it's still there but it was apparently
very close to the Paul Kruger gate go
and look for it go and look for it what
are we gonna look for for car number
[Music]
Loreena I love to hate my mobile device
but it has been through so much
I have accidentally thrown it it's not
on purpose
it has fallen out of handbags pockets
I've stood on it a few times it gets ya
drops a lot flings off tables that are
know how it does that's magic it gets
dropped on the pavement a lot as well
Lots
I don't know but it's not the actual
screen it's the screen cover and then
every time I drop for it I tell it how
much I appreciate it that it hasn't
completely broken although I would like
a new phone and time for an upgrade mine
say mm and like 60 this is also the
longest I've ever had any cell phone in
my entire life
but first iPhone ever got ahead for a
day and then I smashed it whoops
not on purpose not on purpose just it
slipped a triptan I fell probably what
happened okay since well where does Cal
number even like to hang around st. roll
but she's a promise she's not gonna be
on same drill I think we might go down
cheetah cut line is just check if she
hasn't gone a little bit further east
all right we're all doing loops and laps
today looking for the wonderful things
let's see if Steve is going to find a
catch before we do
mmm
loops and laps indeed a Madagascar
cuckoo I'd be very surprised I've never
seen one there's only a few records of
them in South Africa one was of a very
confused male that stuck around in wrong
way area too to call but there was no
female replying so I don't know how long
he will last with that sort of behavior
but if indeed then that is an incredible
sighting definitely on my list to see
but we're still continuing on around the
block here just trying to have a little
look-see and a listen we just come from
galago pan where if the mother was
thinking in sambars 100 position we
haven't seen our bars of the pride for
some time so maybe it's hurt it could be
one of the others may be the youngest
lioness youngest adult not hundred
percent sure it may be going to have a
drink so there were no tracks going to
go and drink but there are still some
puddles kermy I don't know if I want to
be putting the odds on for the sambars
cabs or not some if it is indeed hers
she hasn't had a very good run last year
she really didn't do very well but maybe
she's changed
maybe she in this new year she's got
more you know sort of goals she'd like
to set and maybe the rearing of one cub
at least is one of those goals I don't
know we didn't see any of the Cubs last
year we don't know where she left them
don't know where she left them so they
were on simply Beale arethusa side if
I'm not mistaken
and while the stories were that they
didn't survive
me and my lapel mic curse d'azyr was a
real problem
try not to dance too much in the seat is
that better Craig are you getting some
static there
static sorry everybody is a microphones
come down our back and then are attached
to our body and got to try and not move
too much which is impossible for me okay
so we had a tracks here this morning the
last set of tracks we had two around
here and so she went kind of down this
way there's a two-track coming up that's
gonna take us into the drainage now
we're at one of the there's a track
there where one of the hyena dens
previously I never saw it active but
definitely is an old hyena den we're
gonna just poke her nose down there and
see if maybe we can find any more tracks
but she definitely walked along this
road the rest of the prided mork today
before their tracks her a little bit
ahead of us you could tell by the
freshness okay well it seems like pets
arrival back in the Mara has brought
with it its own problems with regards to
lightning and thunder and he is powered
down so it's not to fry himself I'm sure
he is very excited to be out in the rain
no doubt they've switched everything off
they've covered the sides and they're
just going to be waiting it out those
storms do come and they're do go well
they generally go sometimes they they
don't but they come out of nowhere
there's lightning storms up there and
bearing in mind we've got a very big
aerial on the back and if you do stay
powered up and the aerial can shot and
well we could potentially have all sorts
of damage and injury to ourselves in the
vehicle so we'll let Pat sort of hang
out there a little bit more okay so to
track is coming up in a moment if I
haven't already missed it the grass has
grown very very long so these little
accesses a little bit sort of washed
away or grown away
yeah
Chris I think you know the answer to
that Chris I'm not going to try a morula
coming out of an elephant's bottom today
or tomorrow and I fear that within a
week there will be no more from rulers
in elephant poo so it will be done I
won't get the opportunity so sad you
know I don't know if any of you noticed
this morning but Craig managed to frame
me up ours vomiting on the site there we
go to check it was ours mock charging
hours mock charging and I couldn't watch
anymore and then some of you lovely
people posted some photos of of the
before paulie's face in the after of the
fruits as well and that just brought on
a fresh part of me being an unsatisfied
with my breakfast so no Chris I'm
definitely not going to be trying a
morula fruit and if Taylor is keen to
try to do it again she probably just
needs to step out of her car and grab
some from the fresh manure that no dart
is going to be surrounding a cop from
the elephants she's just found what and
reach up and take one straight from an
elephant next year maybe Steve next year
when I'm big and strong we've got some
elephants but I don't know if they're
gonna be here for much longer I hope
they stay cuz we're on gari main at the
moment so they could cross into little
gari please don't cross and half of them
have already gone in just stay here ah
wonderful
are you ready since I'm gonna go forward
and get you a much better view cuz these
ones are gonna have a med bar yeah I
think it's also have a mud bath
elephants I need to cool down I've got
long pants on I made a mistake run
little one hi mom don't be trust with us
please I just want to watch just want to
watch I know it's weird but I just want
to watch hi girl
hello no they're not having any of it
I think they want to go to the other
side rather no go to baboon pan then you
can have
well overtime or an elephant overtime
you can do that too hmm very indecisive
oh that was sad oh well hopefully we'll
find lots more elephants today can you
help me search for Columba she only
weighs about maybe 30 kilt no not even
there probably like 20 kilos she's got
spots on her years no isn't very long
whiskers you see you know anyways having
a bit of a scratch of the air and off
they go dawn since always our content
today everything's running away it's got
a log cuts on we can watch them a little
bit longer you sorry since you're doing
lots of really of labeling today
oh no they're they're good so they might
pop out again at the boon pan I'll keep
my fingers crossed that they go there
coz it's nice and open and there's a lot
of water around and it seems to be a
favorite spot at the moment for the
elephants to have a look quite a wallow
but just a mud spraying session and just
always fantastic to watch it looks like
they've done that earlier today though
it's slightly dried on their backsides
nice and crusty
that's quite a cool like that elephant
in the leaves no no if she goes straight
through no problem oh she's picked up
the pace quite a bit maybe she had a bit
of a speed wobble there's a couple of
little ones in there too which are very
sweet oh this is a bit of a drop I also
hope that I can see Daryl or Fang before
I disappear that would be really nice
what happened little elephant did you
trouble over there's a serious drop
there may be an old wallow that's dried
up then I thought the grass okay I don't
know if Daryl will come back actually I
don't know where Daryl is at the moment
because Shannon who used to work at
earth lodge he was the one that was
always posting pictures of Daryl
but she doesn't work there anymore so
now I don't know if anybody loves Dara
like we used to love Darrell I'll have
to phone candy my old tracker and ask
him to let me know when he is around I
think that might be the only way all if
he climbs up onto the roof he's sure to
make papers funny elephant that can
we're gonna come back here Oh add a cat
I'm really surprised we have sorry
everyone this is gonna be my life today
and the queen of the animals
disappearing like this gonna be one of
those I see ha ha challenge accepted
animals I will show everyone person says
awesome sighting it was spectacular the
best day Co sighting I've had in my life
the longest one to
no tell me cuz phone I didn't even hear
what you said but you said your uncle
see look how beautiful this is cold law
cold or cold and why is it called that
but why is it called colds law does it
have a secret meaning okay so if you
don't know what that means apparently
there's something called Cole's law
where essentially as the directors go
live live then the animal disappears do
you guys still say live live now you
just go alive do you don't adjust you
live now I remember what I've even been
listening to and I've heard it like four
times today already me oh are you still
do that long nine five four three two
one fresh cuts picture break up if you
can yeah wish you could all hear the
terror in a directors voice when there's
picture breakup or something goes wrong
and you'd say it's the end of the world
guy stationary and Link what else do
they say that's really funny Kirsten
sells lots of lame jokes those are never
funny
and it will suck all the directors son
Emily XE they don't really but that's
what I hear I just changed it sit there
and they probably mock us all the time -
Kirsten what do you say about the
presenters what are the presenters do
that you guys certain talking nonsense
of art in vinyl control not cousins not
gonna say anything she's gonna let me do
the whole show by myself katanas we want
to hear I like to make fun of myself I
always say bad things about myself
before anyone else can say them I think
that's clever
and I'm waiting for Kristen to tell me
what they mock us about
well they can't think of anything
because we're just so perfect the
cameraman and present
kristance is the question women guide
sorry you did we couldn't hear you
getting names wrong that great econ
standard when we get your name John
we're really sorry about that I'll just
apologize on behalf of all presenters we
don't mean to say your name wrong
it's just that nasally accent that comes
through from the directors so if I say
sins or verses things off Kimberley and
then you gotta guess then you gotta win
it and this will just keep ourselves
entertained for the day
yes that's that's exactly what happens
so now you know the truth is arts
believe this very funny anyway so that's
so that's that's that really should we
do a drive-thru yeah okay so Colombo was
not what she went through the Malati I
still think her general direction is
gonna be East so if she's hanging she
was excited about all sorts of things
this would be a very good area for her
along the drainage line we just saw a
Dakin well you didn't get to see it but
I promise I saw one so beast and Balkan
day care and lots of random things maybe
lots of squirrels too and Franklin's a
sketch of Franklin's catch all of the
Franklin's can do some birding as well I
forgot we allowed to do birding mmm if I
can remember the birds no and there's no
birds
so we'll just we'll look we'll drive
very slowly and just check around here
to make sure don't Keystone's come
nineteen guy station II cuz there's nice
signal yeah can you go across this to
you so I'm gonna send you across to
Steve now and it's here his directors
voice
don't panic cursed will be okay
Taylor's just losing signal for a moment
curse never panics though she is the
director today and she never panics I've
never seen Kirsten or heard Kirsten
panic but anyway we are just pop down
there and there's nothing that we can
see Taylor wants me to mimic what to
directs it sounds like in my ear I'm
trying to think whose panic lately hmm
Craig a whose panic lately about signal
faith doesn't panic
she's quite calm Megan was always very
calm Kirsty is very calm it's possible
with some of the new directors there
might be a little bit of panic because
just they're trying to get their head
around all of these things so I'm
looking at I'm not gonna miss some
elephants over there I'm not going to
pull any names out because you know it
is a difficult job I don't think I could
do with these guys - and suddenly you
with someone associate all static and
then look there's going to be some panic
of course an issue as cool as a cucumber
like you Kirsten not everyone on red can
be as cool as you can okay well we're
just gonna get around the corner yeah
there's some elephants there in the
drainage we were just swear by that I
ended in it's just so thick I'm just not
I'm not even chancing getting out even
for a moment to have a little look there
we're gonna have to try a little bit
harder on foot one day see if we can
find the tracks coming in or out or even
just a more positive area but then as I
said once again there's more Eddie's
here doing their thing and the bush as
you saw with Taylor's elephants just not
just swallows them up so if the bush can
swallow up an elephant can you imagine
what it does to a lion a lion is in that
for that matter with little Cubs
impossible and potentially dangerous you
notice we use the term potentially
dangerous because it's only potentially
dangerous if you decide to go in there
now they're not dangerous animals they
don't want to be dangerous but
corner and mother with her cups your
corner any of you ladies back home
you've got kids your corner one of your
kids and you know what's gonna happen
am i right indeed but no one would call
you dangerous with that but a mother
with youngsters is potentially dangerous
indeed indeed I've never had any kids of
my own so I don't really know what that
feeling feels like to have that
all-consuming need to defend your
offspring but a Byers is a formidable
lioness she is a very big girl and for
the most times she's also one of the
lionesses and the one goomar product
gives you that funny look normally
anyway hello Eloise
well we going to assume that the Cubs
are from one of the Avoca males I saw
her mating with blondie but then she
probably made it with more than he mated
with all three of the brothers she
didn't mind she just just did what she
wanted to do so mm Boz was mating while
I was in the Mara and then I came back
and I got her I think on one of my first
or second drives back and she was mating
with I think it was the blonde male and
that was near chitwa but other than that
I haven't seen her with any of the
others but it's not uncommon for the
lionesses to to have more than one of
the male's we saw that with the sausage
tree pride with your Tanya Pike males
they most certainly sort of moved around
the two males one at a time different
days it was very very interesting for me
to see how long the tree-climbing
lioness was actually mating for or as
kinky Telex she when I got to the marsh
she was mating for two solid weeks which
I've never heard of you know you can
read anything you want in the book and
you can study whatever you like you see
elephants have disappeared study
whatever you like and in the Lions or
the animals and all of this will
surprise you so we had some elephants in
the distance but now as you can see the
bush has swallowed them up Craig's gonna
see if he can frame something there but
um it's very thick
very thick we we long for the grass and
the trees to grow back again and then
when they're due just like the woodland
kingfishers arrival we can't wait for
them and then when they hear were like
okay enough of your noise you can go
away now but now the grass is very long
and the trees are very green and the
bush is looking a very very healthy I
must add I must add okay so I mean
driving very slowly around this block
trying to see if there's any signs or
activity coming through
crafty which is the most protective
animal in the bush well all mums are
protective of course but you know you've
got to bear in mind that the bigger you
are there I suppose the more protective
you can be yeah there's a beautiful
laughing dub sitting on top of the
termite mound there Craig er after our
segment this morning with the breeding
herd we moved to this termite mound for
some safety in case there are more
elephants to follow so I would say an
elephants are pretty protective very
predictive in fact but then of course
lions and leopards for their youngsters
most of the other animals that we know
of they're able to or a lot of the other
sort of potentially dangerous ones their
youngsters are the hide away or hidden
in burrows which means the adults don't
need to be protective but a lioness
because the youngsters are sort of just
hidden in the little bush they're not
really protected she will not run away
elephants obviously can only run as fast
as the babies and so they will
definitely stand their ground and Rhino
can also be quite protective although
they will often try and move their
youngsters away rather than confronting
the danger but that is not always the
case
Buffalo are well known for turning on a
predator and as we heard they also well
known for running away from men on foot
so but I wouldn't say that that doesn't
make them protective so it's a very sort
of very good question but males
generally they're quite sort of what's
the word quite softly spoken as it were
and they'll often move away whereas
lionesses will stand their ground for
the protection of the youngsters
very good
well the Laughing dove is definitely not
a protective individual and the reason
it's easy to identify laughing dove as
if we go in closely there Craig oh it's
the only dove you'll see around apart
from the Emerald spotted which is quite
characteristic because of the green
spots on the wings has got a look much
different sort of color but it's the
only dove that we really notice without
a ring on the neck it's laughing because
it doesn't have a ring that's quite easy
to remember and for now it's just
enjoying a little bit of Sun hello see
now yeah no dubs actually feed on seeds
they're exclusively seed eaters and they
normally walk around on the road feeding
on seeds but I think this one's too
rather enjoying the view right now yeah
I don't often see a dove just perched on
the top of a termite mound just doing
its thing I mean I'm not saying they've
they've never eaten termites as possible
that they might from time to time but
I've never heard of a dove eating err
too much many of the seed-eating Birds
that we get will actually feed their
chicks insects in the beginning stages
to give them moisture but doves and
pigeons are unique in their ability to
feed their chicks pigeon milk which is
still created in their crop but by the
production of interesting things but
they eat seeds and that's able through
that they're able to make their own
pigeon milk which they feed their chicks
so they're not the one of the seed
eaters that need to eat any insects some
of the other seed eaters some Oh
certainly probably will grab a few
termites
take them back to the nest or
grasshoppers and caterpillars things
like that to supplement the diet of the
youngsters because it's not many birds
that bring water back to the nest so you
need to provide that through the food
that they give very good what a
marvelous enos not often you get to just
see a bird just sitting here here's the
injured or something I think he's just
he's one of those cool zen-like birds
that's enjoying the view beautiful pink
beautiful beautiful bird well the
Laughing dove is not laughing right now
he's just enjoying some sunshine
while Taylor seems to be moving towards
the south she's gonna go try her luck
around a Chitra damn so Kristin has put
on an accent now but the funny thing is
she still just sounds the same so little
Lita smooth they get April and Saint me
a Miss nobody elephants and shut to a
dam but I might a little bit late cuz
I'd had my phone in airplane mode ooh
and and then I'm quite a bit of a
problem but know how long it'll soon
because I didn't check it I just drove I
did a u-turn and I drove straight yeah
so we shall see in like cuz we're almost
down at the dam I'm also just doing a
good old scan as we go down
hehehe even if it's Cebu yeah
I've been hanging around here eat all
that she would should register
as either East I see marilla trees but
not even an elephant
apparently this was a little bit of
signal breakup so but it's fine now it's
fun be good it's the little dips that
get us
and there lots of tree not mine elephant
in such a sea elephant footprints we all
go and check towards the ashram okay
where are we looking what do you want to
look at sales oh we're having a brief
look at stupid down is empty it's just
water animal lies it's so crazy I
suppose there's so much water around
that the hippos can go over there like
an arm there's some crocodiles since you
down there sensor you see them there are
two rocks in the middle of this little
open patch
I can't reach down here yeah those
things we can look at those there's two
crocodiles they those are not rocks and
you still not see them since those gone
blind everybody please excuse it there
those things it's so good see them for
ages so that's most likely Vladimir and
Boris just relaxing as they all do all
the animals like to relax and use that
word to describe what animals are doing
fairly frequently it's probably not the
most correct term but you know we just
wing it enjoying themselves I'm actually
surprised they're not out this afternoon
warming themselves up because like I
said it hasn't been particularly hot
throughout the day and the Sun has
finally broken through the clouds so if
I was a crocodile I would be gathering
as much heat as I could but again that's
just me and I probably would crocodile
wrong anyways and then there's a few
hippo there's a small pod not too far
away looks like some young ones that are
having a bit of a play
suppose all these long ones have grown
up so much now see the light is lovely
don't you think but we can't get close
to them anymore because it you got to
drive integer - Adam these days that's
what I was waiting for that sound does
the pointing only one hip I want you to
sing this beautiful song hmm oh well
okay since all we are going to continue
what are we going to find we going to
look at water back next cuz they're
walking on the dam wall you just checked
on here so there are elephant tracks but
where did it go lots lots of nights oh
look marilla's lots of people died again
okay Elizabeth
we will be stopping a little bit further
forward like this so you don't scare the
water back so give them ample
opportunities to climb down and do
whatever water back do very very nervous
little ones not too sure why everybody's
stopping adults not convinced what are
they done Kirsten whose name have they
changed it's obviously gonna be a big
story all the colorful that one is
you're not even fluffy your coat is so
smooth aqua bucks okay cool that's
apparently the new name aqua aqua aqua
box and then it sounds like a type of
currency if you ask me yes sir I'll have
two doughnuts and a large coffee and
then they would be like thank you so
much it'll be 36 aqua bucks already
I'm obvious there's nothing else to talk
about today so it's gonna be ridiculous
please she's mean it is Sunday
I hope you're all following instagram by
the way check out at safari lab
officials instagram page follow it if
you aren't like all the pictures you
like a minimum of ten and then share it
with your friends and family so they
also follow it but this is very precious
look at them that little one is so small
it still a different color right we're
gonna carry on and look for that
enormous herd of elephants that was
supposedly here it should wear down
steve has got something much smaller
than an elephant could ever be everybody
we found some butterflies mating now I'm
trying to identify which butterflies
these are they're sitting on a very nice
air ghostess inflorescence and they are
attached bottom to bottom they are
mating now I think it is one of the
whites but I'm not sure I thought it was
a brand burned white but I haven't found
it in the book yet so if any of you out
there are butterfly experts please do
sin through your answers if you do know
who these butterflies are there clearly
are the same species one is probably
male one is probably a female but I'm
sure they fall underneath the white
category but trying to find out which
one exactly is going to take me a few
more moments so it's definitely not the
brown veined white which I had a feeling
it might have been
African common whites it could be it
could be there's such similarities in a
lot of these butterflies in the book
that you've gotta know exactly what
you're looking at so it possibly could
be a African vein white or a common
African common white but I do stand in
everyone else's opinion if you have any
ideas what butterflies these are that
might and are mating me let us know
hashtag safari live one meadow white is
a very common butterfly found across the
country potentially could be but I don't
think so I wonder if any of my butterfly
experts are watching today giraffe girl
well I'm always pleased to bring you
some new sights and mating butterflies
although not as exciting as mating
elephants is still part and parcel of
what goes on Archer this time of year
and talking about the thick bush and
about how dense it is well the
butterflies are finding some very nice
respite on the edge of that little grass
stalk and a little bit of a love affair
happening right now but I'm not sure who
it is differently a white but which
white everybody helped me out there if
you don't mind no guess is it okay so
maybe a mid or what although it doesn't
have the same orange to it
pinky Urich an African common white it
was one of the birth what are the ones I
I think I said initially African common
white it's just the male doesn't seem to
or the male does actually seem to be
there just have a little bit of a read
here and find out offered in the same
are grating swarms as the brand veined
whites male resembles the brown van
white so that is very possible a female
and a male mating I'm very very good
so the female is white and the male is
got the yellow but everyone together
you'll find a female that's also got the
yellow so it is one of those things
everybody take your screenshots we make
sure that we tag the experts in there
because I must admit butterflies or
something I'm a still working on James
Richard has commented and said the
African common white well sir I do know
you know your butterflies quite well and
I'm super excited that I was able to
actually get that in a list of three so
it is a work in progress but I suppose
once you've learned how to guide the
guide book and you can find them quite
quickly but also once you've seen enough
butterflies you can kind of go to the
area in the book that you want to look
at and whites we went straight for the
whites and well if you're agreeing that
as an African common white well then our
bow to no experience and very very nice
I wonder James Richard if it is a new
species for you
probably not but have you all seen their
mating before because if not well they
would go brought to you Roger live on
safari live I wonder cursed should we do
a little broadcast yet to the world I'm
only joking I'm only joking the only
action here is between the two
butterflies
okay well all I can say is that they are
much more interesting than lions mating
because Lions mating are very short and
there's not too much sort of injured
seemingly enjoyment in it where these
two while having a little bit of a love
affair now maybe maybe they've died and
they've just attached themselves there
they haven't moved
they haven't fluttered once but you can
see the the spot pattern on the wing is
those little dots along the edge
seemingly quite characteristic or the
fair bit of variation in the colors well
we haven't managed to relocate on the
elephants we saw you see a bush behind
is very very dense but we're going to
leave this couple to their business and
let's go back over to Taylor who seems
to found another elephant nobody found
an elephant that's got its bottom facing
us Oh lovely so I did not find the
enormous breeding herd that was
supposedly here but what I did find is a
single bull going straight towards
church where or being summoned on the
radio standing by
please say that again I can't hear you
guys it's breaking up sorry everyone I'm
just trying to try on a gang driver I'm
on the northern end of the airstrip yes
please copy thank you very much sorry
everybody pardon pardon pardon radius on
so we're different sounds like robots
they see the robots are taking over the
world child of the universe told us this
morning those robots where if the robots
were gonna take our jobs away anyways
the zoo elephant does not robot is a
real living thing and he's a young bull
he's lovely not unusual to see him on
his own of course and he's just
mentioning away not being obliging to us
so Ken's some of the animals please just
be kind
hey Saenz oh and just nice for you to
fall easy cuz now they just he's just
hanging behind the bushes and I conquer
the other side cuz he's gonna be right
up against the fence so we're gonna have
to leave him i elephant that's very nice
of you to do that to us very mean oh it
looks like Chitra is gonna be having an
Bush dinner should we go and look and
see what stuff they put out this is my
favorite thing if you want him to come
on a safari certo certo is a lovely
place to stay and I'll show you why they
do a strip dinners not Kirsten you don't
get favors anymore you live in
Johannesburg nom let's look this is my
favorite part
they do amazing things I've got a pizza
truck
they have cool sundowners their snacks
are really nice this is first hand
experience
child of the universe has now said that
the robots are coming for me look at
this I mean it's not much right now but
it's going to be spectacular I just have
to show you so we've got tables and
chairs they will be decorated nicely
with white tablecloths I think why not
just making it up but took they're very
fancy here and then they've got they Len
nasal the tables and chaise and I'm so
that'll be nice so that'll go in the
middle
it doesn't look glamorous now because
they're preparing then on the left and
the cage you gotta have lanterns cuz
lanterns are very dangerous so they've
got to stay locked up like that and then
of course a beautiful candle holders
look how lovely those are and then
that's the barbecue grid over there so
that's quite nice I feel like I'm in
Beauty and the Beast now what was i
character's name who was the candle
holder mm-hmm and I think he sang songs
was beauty in the beasts hair not going
crazy Kristen is not bored of me talking
about nonsense please come aside
chitter-chatter lovely off you go to the
Mara with Patrick where it's apparently
a know a whole lot more entertaining
well sometimes mother nature likes to
pull your pants down bend you over her
knee and give you a big old smack on the
bottom then leave the room without
telling you why that has happened to me
right now so the reason we lost kinky
tail is because she bought us through a
very treacherous patch of terrain and
what we were trying to navigate it
that's when she gave us the slip so what
we did was we circle back around came
through more and more terrain more mud
more mud hands well still no sign of her
but I didn't get in the marshmallow Club
which very very very nearly could have
happened and I'm sure Lauren it would
have loved that if I did take the takes
the focus off her last little incident
so we just came back and looking along
the tree line now because it had been
heavily raining so perhaps they had
seeked out some shelter earlier on but
it doesn't seem to be any sign of the
rest of the pride and as for kinky tale
well she is also nowhere to be seen but
we do have what looks to be like a
raptor in this tree giraffe girl giraffe
cow yes I will definitely find you a
giraffe we actually came across quite a
few before so I can actually head back
down that way I don't think I'm gonna
find the sausage tree pride in this area
so I do need to move off anyway so we
see looks like a juvenile or not it's
actually sure which species this one is
those ruffled feathers very cold
they only 17 degrees Celsius so anyway
without further ado let's press on look
for this giraffe and hopefully hopefully
hopefully pick back off on something to
show us where the Lions are
so giraffe girl those giraffes that we
saw before there are about seven of them
and they were all within a pretty close
facility of one another so I'm pretty
confident they'll be able to seek them
out again we do apologize earlier on we
did have to power down for a little bit
that was just because as I said it was
raining very heavily and we had a lot of
lightning so someone has chimed in and
said that that was a Brianna snake eagle
and I think that you are correct did say
that there was no real feathers from the
legs down so I didn't catch the name of
foodcourt got that one but good on you
thanks for your help I did actually do a
bit of birding back in Australia in a
quaint little coastal town called port
nose rope rope so I just got my house
been stuck then and there's a nice
little bird bird keep there and you just
stand there and watch birds for hours
and I didn't have no identification
guide but did really actually enjoy it's
the first time I'd ever done anything of
that sort in Australia so I have a
safari live to thank for that
and it appears I also have Lauren to
thank for identifying that bird so yeah
thank you
but yeah it was also amazing just to see
how much doing this for Safari live has
actually changed my perception on
Australia going back there I'm really
taking no the seat of a lot of things
that happen on land obviously I'm quite
familiar with what happened sorry I'm
just gonna go back and make another turn
quite familiar with what happens in the
water in Australia but not so much on
land so to really see these little
interactions between all these species
that I never would have even thought of
picking up on in the past it really over
the whole new dimension to my trip back
home
focusing on land as well as water it's
really great
Jules it most definitely is a lot cooler
here in the Mara than it is in Australia
so in Australia we were getting up to
one day we had 48 degrees Celsius it was
an absolute stinker of a day and so most
of the time it's been up around you know
3540 degrees so to be here in the 17
degrees of the Mara is well it's chilly
so I've got this honey
well still no sign of lines and still no
signs of anything else so the race on
its roof lioness giraffes send you back
down to South Africa with Steve and a
poodle well thank you very much Pat Pat
was telling me certain things before he
left about swallowing what his mindset
will be when he gets back to Australia
after being yeah for three months or so
so interesting to see how it has indeed
changed him the bush will always change
you everybody once African buggers but
did you open for life and while Craig is
very excited because we managed to find
ourselves a heartbeat in the African
wilderness this afternoon and well what
a beautiful animal it is indeed it could
whoo and while she is also quite
tentative of moving through the thickets
yeah because well it is so dense she's
also having a little bit of a view or
from the termite mound she's being
plagued by all sorts of flies there
which are all just gunning for any
moisture her nose her eyes she's trying
to suck us in who knows there Craig look
at that
almost feels like she's going to
hyperventilate but that's what these
animals do stand very still move he is
just slightly and try and pick up on any
smell that might be wafting around and
maybe she can smell maybe she can smell
and by small tests look like she's got a
white moustache she looks like she's
been drinking a milkshake she's had a
lips in the milk and I've never noticed
it so so fuzzy there we go
such a fuzzy face here's a little bit
jagged a life of walking through thick
bush but look at the amount of flies on
her face now how many of you art there
we need to ask Pat this as well cuz he
comes from a land of quarks around hats
do not flinch when flies land on your
body while the kudu doesn't seem to
flinch Stephan Ventura ball here doesn't
lack flies at all how about you Craig
Craig's not a huge fan so how many of
you can stand deadly still as flies
crawl over not only your body but your
face if you're a kudu you need to any
sudden movements give away your very
camouflaged position I can't stop
looking at that slips thumb I'll doing
thanks for pointing that out
she's definitely the Patil yeah I don't
know if any of you've been on a farm and
milked cows my grandfather used to have
a cattle farm many years ago and we used
to drink the milk straight out of the
bucket after milking it was warm and
foamy and while it used to leave a mark
like that on our lips she finally
decided that Craig did does eat meat and
she's decided to disappear and gone she
is flight and fright or flight and stand
very still strategy that could
neeyala bushbuck employ stand very still
quietly then the rudder short distance
then stand very still again it works
very very well
we were Tenggara two weeks ago and to
Steen boxing that's just Stood Still
again and he didn't know what to do he's
like where did that go like that that
sudden movement and then just stillness
and well is one of the strategies that
work at chef for the thicket loving
animals and seems to work it's used to
work for them
we're gonna continue on down here we've
given up on on our search therefore for
that lioness for their cubs it's just
way too thick so we're going to do a few
concentric circles so we're doing some
concentric circles as we move away from
that area
xenia she did she took offense to me
talking about her mustachio
I wasn't really talking about it mister
she's talking about how she looked like
she drank some fresh foamy milk maybe
seen it on a cow a little cough after
it's suckled it's got all this foam
around its mouth very funny to see very
funny to see well there's lots of birds
flying through here I wonder there's all
fork-tailed drongos and the like emerald
spotted would dove calling we might just
switch off see if we can get you some of
these birds just offered that at the
nine o'clock there Kreger maybe that's
ten o'clock a couple of birds in the
tree there I think they're foretell
drongos we can compare them to the
previous ones that we saw much bigger
beak much firmer body see the beaks
match the cap the tails not always a
giveaway because this time of year
there's lots of young folks held wrong
those around which have also got a
little bit of a paler color and a little
bit of sort of downy feathers on they
don't have the full dark metallic color
to them and see how that one's tail
feathers also weren't completely erupted
so sometimes you can mistake a
fork-tailed ronger with a with this
other black flycatcher but of body shape
and the thickness of the beak it's a
good thing to look for
and I personally believe that the the
southern black flycatcher actually
mimics that of the folks out jeonga
because who wants the most of the folks
are jongo it's like cheetah cubs
apparently resemble honey badgers
because who wants to mess with them
nobody does nobody does want to mess
with them
so bird in the road just to compare to
the laughing dad before he has two
clearly a ring neck dove caper turtle
devil walking in the road
you see he's not laughing because he
does it he does have a ring on his neck
walk around feeding on seeds and one of
the one of the interesting
characteristics at seed-eating Birds
have is they've got sort of a polarized
lens on their eye which enables them to
actually differentiate between seeds and
sand grains obviously they will still
ingest a few sand grains to work in the
gizzard for the breaking up and the
crushing of the seeds but they're able
to see the difference in the reflection
of a seed versus a sand grain because
obviously the sand grains are bit more
shiny they're very very small but they
do have a sheen to them and so they're
able to discern the difference between
them which is very very interesting okay
walking a lot of walking is done by
these individuals and if you look at the
track you'll notice that they walk with
their toes facing inward and that's
where people get that the phrase from
when someone walks pigeon-toed when they
walk with their toes in you call it
pigeon toed and then if they walk with
their toes out they call duck-footed
and when you see geese or ducks tracks
they walk like that anim you see pigeons
very interesting so I didn't get the
name before they're cursed but now I've
never seen a shoe bull who ever asked
that question I would love to see a shoe
bull the friend of mine recently has
been up and taken some amazing photos
but sandstoe I have not seen a shoe book
but I would like to very strange-looking
animals very very strange and they
almost apparently they don't do anything
for hours they just sort of sit there
looking very funny because if you've
seen them they've got the strangest to
face
well suppose the beak in the face
combines just make it very strange and
they just stand that they do absolutely
nothing
Hey well I'm not gonna have to do
something because there is a tree in the
right
I wonder if this vehicle has got a panga
if not I'm going to have to push it with
my very strong arms back
let me guess Chris do you want to wait
and watch me push it with my strong arms
or am i changing link away 5 4 3 2
what okay there's a bit of a delay so
when I ask a direct question I've got to
Joburg
then generally it takes a bit of delay
for them to get back to me but let's see
if we are able to oh this is not gonna
be easy Craig I think Craig might have
to help me this is not going to work No
not so strong after all but if we don't
have a panga which we don't have in this
vehicle we're going to have to just make
a little detour around it I do apologize
everybody we will address this sorry
Craig
okay well while we get around this
obvious roadblock in the road let's go
back down to Chitra area with Taylor and
see what she's up to this time we
decided to look at a Marilla tree oh
wait look there's a lipid hahaha this is
why we were waiting around and to
it now there is a lipid s in the tree
whether it is it is
maybe sandy oh good Java I can't see
that other side of her face that I can
just see three spots on the left but
either way both lipids both mother and
daughter have three three that's a
little bit difficult to tell from here
but I've been closed on these the lipid
experts on the interweb please go ahead
please tell me who this lipid is that
it'd be fantastic but I'm gonna go ahead
and say it's either Dundee oh good Java
but it's difficult to see from here am i
right on gar remain as well could be
cassava could be done you both have
their territories around here don't
think it's Cebu yeah though she's
fishing she's went five five if I'm not
know that she do do I forget a lot of
you are saying it's definitely late but
thank you so much I thought that maybe a
cheater had climbed up and drew the tree
thank goodness no coach I was too - no
see boy I don't know why I said that so
he Sibley rose to do there we go James
Richard leopard extraordinaire in
Karstens words and he deserves that
title I might add and has confirmed that
it is indeed kochava wonderful she's my
favorite lipid of the northern sabi
sands so that's always nice that's
really lovely to see the last time I saw
kochava I'm pretty sure she was the
selected that we drove past we all
remember that remember that one time I
drove past a late
live because we were too busy not
concentrating we were looking for a
lipid because the lipid had run across
the road then we found an another lipid
elsewhere huh that was a good time it
was one of my fondest memories said no
one ever
and well everyone says that except me
but very cool to see but of course fast
asleep and what a fantastic place to
have a race though up in the tops of the
tree of a marina pause just dangling
down we will reposition at some points I
just wanted to sort of start here and
then we will work our way around it'll
be nice for show opens our eyes and
looks towards us we should have a good
view which is fantastic there not a lot
of flies at there there you can see
she's not really touching her ears at
all she doesn't seem too bothered and I
can't tell you how the flies were
bothering me today on my walk what she
does have though is a couple of ticks on
her that you can see sternest ah yes she
is making me sleepy - I agree with you
there we go
no she's woken up a little bit maybe
she's just gone huh love people okay
she'll probably do it no I'm going to do
a yarn she is making me tired just
sitting here watching her like this but
pretty awesome to see
no hopefully she'll wake up let me go
have a drink of water go all the way
down to Chitra damn it's a Sherman long
time since I seen a leopard Chitra damn
I think the last time that I saw a
leopard was husana he was owner we saw
one no Jerry but I was on the other side
of the dam anyways I don't we haven't
seen jiminy leopards frequently
frequenting the dam Hasan is empty she
loved it
Dingaan I loved it at one point ah not
so long ago paint he had a cool sighting
of tin gana eating fish that's nice very
very nice everybody likes a bit of
sashimi every now and then apparently
Tim garner does too the was he
quite then or did he just I suppose you
would have just come across the fish
from there the fishy kills maybe not
completing a meal and I think we often
forget that lipids are particularly big
scavengers - they'll take whatever they
can get and there were a whole lot of
fish that had died and they were lip
there was a leopard and a whole lot of
hyena has or that it'd be really funny
to watch a hyena eat a fish I mean it's
one thing we sort of put a cat and fish
sort of - and - and feasting upon one
another I think that's because we've got
domestic cats but I ena eating fish
that's so fascinating I wonder if those
fish had died because of the sort of
putridness of the water remember I told
you that one time at earth Lodge and I
was working down inside wasabi that's
actually cleaned the dam because in the
drought all the hippos were defecating
in the last remaining waterhole and it
was terrible there were way too many
hippos for that small waterhole and all
the urine and all the feces you know
just killed all the fish it like
deoxygenated the water I think every
single organism in that dam died which
was pretty sad so they kind of had to go
in there and clean it all up we didn't
have the hyenas and the nipper to come
and do that for us
you know just scoop it out with a pool
scoops it was really bad and then close
their dam or for a couple of months till
a don't maybe was a two months he let it
sort of stabilized
then we opened it back up again and then
it hasn't been big drought since so
those are of course extreme conditions
that's so sad to hear lots of catfish in
that dam though so they'll be fine but
nice to see a leopard in a tree
funny enough that's something that you
actually don't get to see all the time
everyone thinks I'm gonna go to Africa
I'm gonna see a limit in a tree no
Christine who's a new viewer hello
welcome welcome and you've asked if this
is the leopard with Cubs and pyjamas I
had Cubs I think another set of Cubs but
no one has seen her with them I think
for a long time I think they suspected
that they've died but I think the
leopard you're thinking of is she do so
she doesn't hang around yeah and she
hangs around a little bit further
towards a West and so it would take
probably about 25 minutes or so to drive
down that side so could either is a
leopard from this area she hasn't moved
too far away from home her mother's name
is ton D maybe you've heard of the name
Tony we speak about her often and she's
had quite a few Cubs you maybe you have
heard of tumba he's been wandering
around not sure to know where he is
maybe some Ghita blonde Aloisi side
somewhere around there and so it's a
little bit further sort of south from
where we are right now which is nice to
see her daughter that normal for the
boys to disperse and females will
normally stick around and then young
Columba her latest offspring at Andy's
datasource ring we saw this morning we
try to find her but she vanished she
might pop out of it later before we go
have a scratch with for her because
unfortunately in a sighting like this
we're not gonna be able to stay here for
particularly long because there are
going to be lots and lots of people I
don't know how busy or quiet is we'll
see and we were honest and by three so
six I'm the sixth vehicle that has
already you know gone through the
sighting and so we'll have to I suppose
take take some turns
and and see how it goes but very very
cool it's kind of an iconic thing to see
a leopard in a tree and when we do
reposition says we reposition quickly
yes that's steal a space I've been very
polite today look at me go we're gonna
go in this road yeah yeah we're gonna
just try Park no case then I'm never
polite to the directors of this
ridiculous
no don't stall in front of the people
don't stall stalled that's why I was
supposed to park like - just like this
so you get a different angle before we
decide to get silhouettes and said shots
ears Kristen I've stalled everything
everyone is laughing at me now but it's
fine whatever I made it look like
professional professional stoner secret
Chavan didn't mind she didn't laugh she
respects the fact that it's difficult to
drive I was going up a very steep hill
just to be fair hey since all pleased
and since all had a big lunch today so
no the cogniser oh she's got a hit up
how amazing that's fantastic since all
I'm just trying to think where we gonna
park because also you see I don't really
get too close to the other vehicles cuz
otherwise we're just gonna get I suppose
in I can take photos and aim it and
everyone else eh yeah okay every way my
secret now so we will reposition but I'm
not gonna do it while we're live because
it's gonna take some serious navigating
to get into the perfect spot Kirsten
says she's gonna tell James on me that's
mean
Godwin tell James
she will get rid of me oh you know we're
gonna lose our spot because there's this
other person that's coming in and
they're gonna take it who is it yeah
we'll have to wait because it's gonna be
very hard as a sort off to spot that but
it's okay it's like my dream shot to get
a limpid silhouette eternal Marilla tree
and I've only been guarding for seven
years so maybe in another seven years
time I'll have that opportunity one day
one day one day oh well at least she can
see a tail now so that's good because
you should still got her tail in case
you were wondering oh thank goodness
Steve has managed to find something else
it was however not of the feline kind
but a creepy crawly nonetheless well
done on finding a leopard I always like
it when one of my colleagues finds a
leopard because then that means we can
talk about caterpillars and leaves and
things I'm just gonna try show him to
you again it's now been so accommodating
until now and now that you've come to us
he's turned around there is come on
little guy
I'll hold it you there cragger how's
that hair you cats a pull up the the
sort of the offspring of a mating
amazing buds of flowers I don't know
what species sisters I have absolutely
no idea but it landed on the chair next
Craig off to my ex Capades trying to
move that tree so we we've driven with
him about maybe five minutes so now it's
as if he's gone on a journey to the moon
he's on a completely different continent
but we've got him on a very nice leaf
when we got it's I can tell you sex to
be honest with you but it's very furry
got very long furry spikes at the Beca
these hairy caterpillars can often be
quite unpleasant to touch it's one of
the defense mechanisms you can imagine
an organism like this it's not capable
of moving very quickly is very easy game
for a lot of birds and whatever
creatures feed on caterpillars the
cuckoos
coming almost exclusively for
caterpillars and so those furs all those
spikes will often deter them from eating
them not always the case though
sometimes your fine Birds catching them
and then wiping them clean hmm Paulette
you want to know if I can tell a
butterfly mouth I'm really not ever to
sit about these things and the best
thing and the only thing to do is to
take it and put it inside of a a
container hopefully you've found the FEU
he's not getting some energy oh here he
comes he's getting some energy doctor of
my words turn a speed there you did put
him on a oh no that's not gonna do
that's not gonna do turn a speed and you
put him on a sort of in a box with the
food that he likes to eat and there's a
very good chance it'll pupate and then
become whatever it is that you're
looking for and generally the cocoon or
the pupa is quite different and
butterflies and caterpillars and you
can't find these things out but here he
goes is on this very dirty piece of
cardboard trying to camouflage in and
you still got him Craig I can't see the
monitor anymore I put him back up here
now he can get him on the track here's
the sprinting track okay so if we had
two of them every one we could do a
little race now call the the the
caterpillar Olympics nope
so they had subtly put on a turn of
speed when they want to nothing is quite
incredible okay well I think it's very
very cute those false eyes or antennae
that are sitting up there
very cool indeed well it's wonderful to
have Pat back firmly even back up in the
Mawr I'm sure he's enjoying it and well
he would like to show you not owning
elephants but he's also got the world's
largest bird well from something very
little to something very huge we just
had quite a funny little sighting it
seems to just settle down now that this
big elephant you're saying who is
harassing these ostriches so I saw it
just out of the corner of my eye I could
see its tail stiffen up it was still
quite a way away from the UM from the
ostriches
and then it just put its head up and
just charged at them and obviously they
moved a little bit but I mean they
didn't actually scatter they didn't you
know disperse they kind of stood their
ground a little bit and then the
elephant just marched through with his
head up trying to look all high and
mighty fine showing them through the
beat boys it was great yeah don't worry
draft girl I still am on the way to fly
into these Gerard's it's just the only
problem is it was a very long drive
between where we are now and where they
are so it's still going about another
10-15 minutes ahead of us until we get
down that way but rest assured I will go
and buy them it looks like yeah this
scene has definitely settled down now
the ostriches are going one way and the
elephants going the other way
I wish we had have seen that just a few
seconds earlier it was very entertaining
I think the elephant would have had a
pretty hard time trying to make actual
contact with an ostrich though they
could move pretty quickly around that
beeping
Tesla nice to hear from you again I
remember you asking us questions on dive
light so there are all the zebra well
the zebra are all away from here at the
moment so we have this thing every year
called the great migration and what that
is is the L device coming up from
Tanzania into the Mara and they do this
towards the end of the year so we are in
earliest parts of the year now so there
are a few zebra around there is there's
definitely not no zebra but most of them
are away for the time being
but they will be back in high high
higher numbers later on in the year of
course with the wildebeest now this
elephant is still up to his tricks he's
now out feeling himself a tree it looks
like he is giving it a bit of a nudge
I'm gonna bit of a scratch now oh that's
nice and on he goes very faithful all
the solids
funny seeing them now all drenched in
rain you could almost think that there
are different subspecies or something
because of how dark they are Paulo sorry
I just didn't catch that guys get that
one more time
Oh Paula can't wait for the migration
neither can i I really hope I am back
here for that this year because I would
love to see it as I said earlier we did
see kind of the remnants of it but not
the full-blown migration because we were
there I was there in November and that's
a little bit after but it still was
quite a few around but geez I would love
to see that River Crossing is definitely
on my bucket list see a huge higher
valleys up ahead I think manure just
showed you that on camera there's been
quite a lot around actually elephants
the easiest thing to spot out here
they're all over the place the other
thing that's also very easy to spot is a
giraffe as well which is why I'm pretty
confident I'm gonna find this ones they
sometime oast of the times are as tall
as all the trees we see so they stick
out like a broken on
looks like the rain is still persistent
it kind of hasn't stopped the whole day
or not the whole day kind of since about
pretty much as soon as I came out here
it's been all started and it's kind of
just been on and off we've been taking
these rain covers on and off a lot today
wow that is a lot of elephants one two
three
there's about 25 odd elephants here I'll
just stop so we can I'll just come a
little bit closer up it's actually quite
a nice scenery we've got little bit of
light poking through the clouds there
and all of these elephants ravindau what
makes elephants knock down trees well
they do this a number of reasons one as
we saw just before with that bull they
like to have a scratch and sometimes
they just accidentally knock it down but
they mostly like to snap off twigs and
break trees so they can eat the bark of
the trees and eat some of even some of
the leaves and anything that they can
get off it it's also great for them
because it's also a strengthening kind
of not exercise but obviously the more
trees they break down using that trunk
it's going to make the trunk stronger
itself there is a lot of muscles in
there some will say 40,000 some will say
a hundred thousand but either way there
is a huge density of muscles in that
trunk and it also helps to really
strengthen that up as well and sometimes
they just do it because they are having
a tantrum especially in younger
elephants I've seen some just rip the
tree out just throw it because they were
in one of their moods that we so often
see young elephants in
ah quite peaceful actually I'd like to
stay here for a few more seconds before
moving on how good is that view
something I'll never get sick of out
here even on such an overcast drizzly
day just that little bit of light
getting through is enough to really hope
you're all enjoying the ambience and I'm
not sure if you're picking up on that
distant Rumble thunder in the distance
low soft sound of rain very beautiful
it's a very easy place to calm your mind
in very easy
it's just a very Zen place very quiet
very open to see for miles
so I'm gonna make my way back onto the
main road and head back down towards
these troughs and in the meantime let's
go back to the vault
down in South Africa welcome back
everyone I do hope that Pat does manage
to find those drafts for you in the
meantime we've got a little bit of a add
of race if you right here they are Nick
and Nick at the moment and in three two
one here we go the first ones jumped
again off you go guys
they're going I got money on the guy on
the Left family is having a bit of fun
here
found two more Cape turtledoves also
known as the ring Nick doves walking
through possibly a mating pair or a
breeding pair and walking around looking
for the seeds that no doubt have blown
onto the road from the the grasses off
to the side nice to see them they're
very relaxed very very relaxed and they
are very interesting doves make a very
messy sort of nest in a tree sort of
like a platform stick nest which they
kind of stick together with their
excrement
so not only them do they make milk they
also stick the nest together like glue
for their babies and the doves can only
have two eggs because they can only
produce so much milk for them so that is
one of the limiting factors behind the
doves but there are so many of dubs
around which goes to show that the
production of milk and the only two egg
policy is still a very successful
strategy art in the wild most other
birds their hedge their bets by having
more than one egg two three four
whatever it might be five six and that's
to basically try and have as many as
they can
- obviously supplement to the population
but doves being one of the most prolific
birds to be seasoned we found around but
anyway enough of these doves this
quickly go back down to kochava and
tailor for a final view
well look at this
finally I recovered from my stall that I
had earlier and now we've got a
spectacular view of kochava just resting
up in the tree but unfortunately we're
not gonna stay here for too much longer
because it is a long line of vehicles
wanting to come into the sighting so
it's only fair that everybody has a turn
but it doesn't look like she's going to
wake up anytime soon
her feet were just twitching though not
that that means too much I think she's
yeah that looks like such a great smart
it always it was impresses me how easy
it is for a laborer to sleep in a tree
like this and how they can stay up there
without falling out of the tree hey
sensor don't you wish you could do
something like that I'm gonna be amazing
every time I try a clean try I try and
climb a tree goodness
and it's oh it's a bit scary sometimes
and I can't do it as well as a leopard
candle so to be honest I don't think any
of us could but it's not like I said I
keep saying it it's not often that we
get to see a cat so clearly up in a tree
especially in green season so that's
perfect we're this is seeping here all
day I especially could have been seeping
here all day like I said to you it was
quite nice because why was it nice since
all ogres was not to what you had to do
but she's not really in the shade at all
but I suppose would have been just out
of the Sun that broke this afternoon oh
maybe she would have enjoyed those last
warmth rays on her body
I was hoping we're gonna be able to see
some old sucker marks or something like
that that's it's a bit of an awkward
angle to try and pick up on anything
like that also sorry if I don't answer
any of your questions I don't have comms
at the moment radio comes the weird
thing is is that sometimes you can move
half a meter and then you don't have
communication at or say so we'll do one
quick closer position because Matt's
just pulled out but I think the next
wave of people are coming
so we'll have to do this very quickly
one of these and then we're gonna have
one minute sighting like this and then
we're gonna have to go I'm afraid no
it's a pity we didn't have the bright
blue sky behind it cuz that would have
been really really nice don't you think
that would have been so stunning would
have been a perfect opportunity for a
silhouetted leopard but I don't think
that that's going to happen at all we're
not gonna really get a sunset I think
the Mar is going to win this evening
although no they hang on they just had
torrential downpour and lightning and
all that sort of stuff so it could be
fair game this evening for a sunset
competition well I just hope the clouds
clear a little bit so that we can see it
but further down into the West but
sleeping soundly she doesn't look too
fat either she probably could do with a
meal saying so can we just look and look
at her stomach quickly it's just let's
just see if we can maybe see any of her
can we is that's as far as we can zoom a
mmm that's a pity we can't zoom any
further I'm afraid so it's very
difficult to see any sort of suckle
marks or anything like that she doesn't
seem to be having much luck she's a
she's a young cat though this is only
her second litter all that she did have
enough unfortunately didn't make it
oh we have a question from scenic hello
what's the difference between South
African neighbors and a Sri Lankan
Leopard really not much at all and other
than I found that the Sri Lankan
leopards tails were slightly longer so
they've got a different name it's pen
therap artist just like the african
tippet but it's pen therasp are Pardus
courtier and they their eye color also I
never saw any lipids with sort of blue
or greenish eyes it would have really
sort of brown hazel eyes and then the
females were substantially larger than
the female leopards here in Africa even
the biggest female leopard I've seen
which was warthog Waller and she used to
live down nigh and sabi sabi and lion
and he should popped into Kirkman's as
well but this was a little while ago and
yes that's really it the tail length but
I didn't see any monster male methods I
saw some that I think Tenggara could
have even been bigger so you know no no
male leopards that look like lioness is
not like amber viola or Anderson male
nothing along those lines but it was
cool and it was really interesting sort
of seeing them they loved the rocks they
love the granite boulders which leopards
love to be in an area where there are
lots of granite boulders unfortunately
they aren't many granite boulders up
here in the northern sabi sands I guess
in Sawle are you ready we're gonna have
to go now unfortunately okay and I've
got one more question I'm going to read
quickly from Ellie and it's about black
leopards and whether we get them here or
not so I haven't seen melanistic and
sorry it's a Land Rover and you can take
it out of 4x4 and then it will try and
hop into 4x4 again or you put it into
4x4 and then it hops out of 4x4 you all
know that you've seen that three hundred
times over so no I haven't seen
melanistic lipids I don't think there's
been melanistic leopard reports here in
the sabi sand me I haven't heard of
anything in the Kruger and I did hear of
the strawberry leopards however in they
just waved hi everybody and so I did
hear of the strawberry leopards in the
term avati actually a hood sprayed
running around some way but I mean of
course is everyone's very excited about
this melanistic Nippert that was seen in
Kenya but I think they were on they're
definitely there but that's just one of
those one of the things with you're
lucky enough to see something like that
so yeah I've I haven't even come close I
know the area that Tristan's it was in
nine India's one of the places he'd sent
me a message saying they just missed a
melanistic leopard by 15 minutes but I'm
not gonna tell you more because I'm sure
he wants to tell you about that but that
was quite exciting I'm so sad for him
because I thought man that would be
something really really cool to see and
and I mean no offense if anybody needs
to see him in elastic knit but it needs
to be Tristan because he's the trust the
leopard King he's also the Tristan King
I suppose so
I actually go Tristan you deserve to see
a melanistic leopard but for me oh
goodness it seizes though Steve is given
up on looking for cats we're gonna give
another bash and looking for Colombo
he's still looking at butterflies I've
never given up looking for cats there's
just there's so many little interesting
things and here we've got another
butterfly which I'm trying to identify
and I'm not sure what it is the closest
I can sort of find at the moment it
falls underneath sort of the arrowhead
family but I don't think it is one of
them I wonder once again I'm going to
call the audience I'm going to ask the
audience opinion any woody hang on a
second standing by something coming in
on the radio
no updates at the moment I would seller
that I know of so just getting an update
there from the West
I thought maybe last time last few times
I've had radio calls like that who can
worry is coming in from the east of the
West and so I was very excited to try
and catch up Matt but anybody hashtag
Safari laughs can you tell us what
butterfly this is that kind of really
does resemble part of the arrowhead
family that's all I can sort of see at
the moment but I suppose if I just
okay so Kirstie is an expert at
butterfly she calls it the white brown
orange stripy butterfly that sounds very
very accurate Kirsty I reckon that is
probably exactly what it's called
compared to some of the other scientific
names I think it's that's pretty short
that's a pretty short scientific name
I'm just gonna keep paging and I'm sure
maybe you think with that very white
sort of line on the wing there that it'd
be quite a characteristic butterfly to
find but I've got a really nice book
I've got some beautiful photos in it but
I'm gonna keep turning until one of you
back home tells me the answer oh I find
it first what do you think Craig who's
gonna win me or the viewers I reckon the
viewers I got matched bid Sean said this
Craig grease the viewers have got a much
better chance you can probably hear me
turning yeah I'm trying to turn very
quickly so that I can win James Richard
you say it's a tube of policeman well
I'm now gonna have to look in the front
of the book to find the policeman's 358
I was only on 246 that's the little way
to go one of the say 358 so James
Richard let's have a look and see how
how well you have identified this 358 oh
wow well done sir it is indeed a -
policeman fantastic various top of the
screen I'm never gonna forget that look
at that guy
very very cool indeed it
likes to hang out on hilltops hillsides
flatlands and the coast and all of the
sort of flower species that I'm looking
at the only one that the really
important novel fruit species is the
concrete soms
so no Doubt's being in this area lots
and lots of concrete soms around and
when I say larval food that is where the
adult will land lay the eggs and the
caterpillars like what we saw before
that very fast little shimmering guy
that was where there lay the eggs and
then obviously hatching on there
fantastic thank you very much
I would have eventually gotten there but
thank you for helping me out there James
Richard
okay good I'm glad tell the universe
added a little bit on the end she said
the guards have to be limited to two
laughs line calls to James Richard so at
least it's not to the audience I can ask
more of the audience then great that's
awesome
okay I need to go and find out what's
going on is it is ruku Maury I think it
might be hookah Marie hang on a second
one I just talked on the radio quickly
last session come for Steve
it's busy talking to someone else
standing back and I come to that side
saying please confirm what you have
come on I think Taylor's right there
she's very very close she's been in a
kochava sighting
copied what have you got there Abel
okay well while we try to figure out
what's going on in the radio here let's
go back up to the Maasai Mara to see if
Patsy's managed to find and fulfill his
promise for giraffe girl for some
giraffe and here we are with one of my
favourite birds in the world - the grey
crowned crane and we are seeing them up
in a tree right now which isn't
completely uncommon but we do often
encounter them on the ground during
daytime most of the time though in the
night they will come up to rest in a
tree you can see these two right here
are doing just that
getting some preening done probably
looking to settle in for the night I
would say try and keep some warmth now I
could probably assume that these two are
a mating pair they are a monogamous bird
so they will tend to form lifelong bonds
once they have found a mate and so if
you see them in pairs you can pretty
safely assume that a beautiful bird so
odd looking but in such a awesome way
everything about them is is so cool the
sad thing is though they are pretty
endangered only 6000 left odd in Africa
so not the most plentiful bird so you
see them in relatively high numbers here
in the Mary's is a great thing probably
every second or third Drive will almost
guarantee you'll see some gray crown
cranes
all right well just another little cool
sighting on the way back dad's sister
Huff's I'm sorry it's taking it such a
long time but things just keep happening
before we had a hyena come right up to
the car but then it kind of just went
off by this before we could get live
again so we've heard yeah quite an
interesting little road trip
Diane can birds fly in rains and storms
well some species can but it is quite
cumbersome obviously you can imagine
birds being so light they can easily be
weighed down by things like water which
has a pretty big choir though yeah it's
it kind of collects in the feathers in a
way and can weigh a bird down so you'll
not often see birds flying about when
it's raining heavily more often when
it's speaking a bit for example when it
was absolutely hammering down before we
were struggling to see anything at all
there was not much movement
oh just got randomly quite a lot darker
I think the Sun must have popped behind
a cloud or something quickest kind of
darkening I've ever seen that was really
strange I'm not sure whether the camera
picked up on that oh nope it just went
from being quite a bright to a lot
darker everyone's wondering where my
shoe tree as well here we go
I don't think I've actually worn line
that will I have it before green of
being a favorite color looking good
thanks thanks Manu Manu says I look good
and the news approval is all I need
I should actually be wearing a Shuker
though shouldn't I this jackets a bit
it's not really traditional for being
out here in the Maasai Mara
we actually went and visited one of the
villages yesterday and it's got ear
jewelry and spoke to some of the locals
and that is such such kind nice people
the Masai
well here's a link that if he had asked
me a couple of months ago if I would do
it I would have said no because she
didn't work here let's go to tailor my
tailor no no you stay though yeah so did
let's see your bling let's see you
jewelry show us Hey since all oh look at
a can maybe we'll get this one which is
pretty no yes we got it longer than the
first run said was an improvement I know
but I'm not you can't just have a sugar
you see we did the bangles and the
necklaces maybe got little anklets I
don't know what pets into you never know
he's an Australian for one anything
could happen
I don't know what wrote him and on I
think I'm on an Ed Wood Road I'm pretty
sure my dad would road we're gonna go
back to run this all the Eternals
I must have a oh no they're coming up I
want to go back and just see if play
lumber is still around I it's just weird
that there were no tracks out on the
road so I don't know if she just was
maybe sleeping in the grass and she's so
comfortable with the vehicles maybe
she's just then one left to hit and be
spotted maybe she's learnt a bath Safari
vehicles and how annoying he can be
already so we'll do one last that will
drive through that off-road track and
then we'll probably the air from venture
on elsewhere and maybe do little
boundary patrol maybe all the way down
guy remain and Triple Aim just to see if
the incomers the Lions don't come back
so we have a viewer from nico nico who
is asking about what i think the animals
must think of us i think they can't
stand us i think they get really annoyed
by us to be honest but they just sort of
put up with us then some of the animals
really like to put on a show
so in the Leopards pose and tension need
for us some of the lines do exactly the
same thing so yeah it's hard to say
obviously i can't communicate with
animals even though I'd really like to
that's like if someone said to me you
can have one superpower what would it be
it would still be to communicate with
animals can you imagine I wouldn't have
to do anything I'd wake up really late
and go and drive on late and then just
you know have an arrangement when it
suited me as to when we would see the
animals so that would be the goal did
you see her yeah I seen some sense of
the monster truck is telling me where my
so try and yeah yes boss yes boss
ah she's on that which took mr. might
actually when we came through so how
funny is this we actually checked this
termite man before I went in the road I
was just about to turn on the to track
I drove further and we stopped and we
stared and we stand we didn't we didn't
come off road because there was no
tracks going in here we did hey she
maybe was sleeping on the other side and
we thought maybe maybe not and then this
years well then since all hi ye
yeah since I can swap seats with me
already I would love to be do the camera
we're gonna be a lot of fun she looks
unimpressed there look at that face it's
like someone just told her that it's
Monday tomorrow and she's got a paper
due that she hasn't even started all
university students and I just thinking
about that has made her exhausted and
she has to have a nap she is petite
though Hey
know when you see her like really ardent
open this morning she was curled up on
the chair my mind I'm walking through
the long grass she didn't really I
didn't think of her sighs away but
knowledge you're sitting and when we're
looking at her face on you can see how
narrow her chest is especially
considering we saw kochava and she's
obviously a fully grown leopard she's
filled out quite nicely she wasn't
particularly thin she's got little
stumpy legs though but you it's not it's
just the way she's sitting what have you
been doing all day girl it's bossy don't
know yes Fiona she does have a turned
each a Sun she definitely does you're so
petite little girl no that's so sweet
maybe she went off chasing squirrels and
birds and her curiosity got the best of
her I mean that could easily have
happened
100% no you're gonna get those gorgeous
eyes she's got a lovely lovely light
colored eyes it's a very pretty picture
you don't often see too many in efforts
with eye color like that
mommy is sort of a lovely golden color
when they're young they're always blue
it's or Austin for photography and then
they tend to change in here the woodland
Kingfisher or there's a pair of them
calling in the distance she's not
excited by that right now
it's nice to hear that corn very very
nice indeed she also looks like she
hasn't been grooming herself
particularly well and easy then look how
shaggy her coat looks rather than it
being nice and slick but I think right
now grooming herself is something that
she's not really worrying about I think
her priority lies in finding us off the
next small meal although she should be
capable enough to bring down a small
Impala or a little de Castilla in
Bacchus Kirsten I think she's going
through that sort of that awkward
teenage daydream I don't want to
pressure my he I'm looking to shower
just once a week or whatever teenagers
do this seems to be the case though to
leopards in one drive that's fantastic
that's like really really cool this is
this is nice though I know I love seeing
Keshava but she was sleep very sleepy
and let's be honest and got super
awkward because of stalled yeah what's
wrong sins on why do you want to come to
me which one meet you can I pose for my
picture okay right everybody it's photo
day
welcome back Taylor and a number now we
need Tristan in the car as well and then
ending on anti Nita rather that'll be
the TT in teen t-shirt
can you imagine that's a mouthful the
Tristan Taylor tiny touch toilet under
ten tenten tenten tenten
the wind is Justin coming back on what I
don't know I think he comes back and
Wayne's day but I don't know if he
starts on Wednesday but he's coming back
are you ready ready for the Tristan
Taylor show that's going to be hilarious
I'm so excited
don't be amazing it'll be a lot of fun
there we go I hope you got my good side
everybody if it's not good I will
complain on Twitter don't think I won't
lemme guess you're gonna go to Steve now
because he wants to have a look at some
butterflies or maybe a caterpillar or
perhaps he's found you a cat in a hat
there's another butterfly right there no
no I just want to show the viewers
anything that's pretty and well seeing
as a leopard was found it makes it quite
nice to just bumble and the birds around
we've got two really nice butterflies
that set around and when shot for us for
ages which doesn't happen I try every
day to get butterflies but they're just
don't sit around I think it's because
it's nice and cool
thus afternoon they're like it's a soul
they don't have this solar panel while
there's solar panels haven't really
warmed up so they're very nice and slow
but what we are going to do everybody
which I'm sure you're going to be quite
excited about is with good answer left
over here we're gonna go straight and
we're going to come to a road called
shoe bomber Road and right there is a a
termite mound in the ground there's a
couple holes in there termite mound it
is well there's a little family of
cuteness living there well they're not
all cute some of them are our bacon and
quite scary-looking that overall there's
a lot of cuteness there so guessing most
of you probably know what I'm talking
about
Kirstie is excited she's just been yeah
in might yep so the radio that was going
on before was just one of the jhummer
stations or public stations calling in
the leopard that they're found in a tree
that obviously taylor has been with
already so he was calling it in and
taylor was in the area and obviously she
knows the lineup but when you're on that
one of the main roads with all of the
south stations and all the vests that's
that could get quite confusing so she's
over there she can deal with whatever's
going on we'll go and see a hole in the
ground how does that sound everybody
sounds exciting and maybe a butter flour
too as well along the way
indeed indeed so we're just along our
fire breaking up in a moment or two
we'll be popping out at the center road
shabam erode and those of you who've
never heard that word before don't know
what it means
shabam is actually a weapon or rifle a
firearm in in local Shang Gong Tsonga
spelt with is it with an X sorry X XI
bar moon just in case you're wondering
what what on earth does that word mean
how it got its name from I have
absolutely no idea no idea it's not as
easy as twin dams road or Weaver's nest
road or Warburg's nest road they all
kind of make a bit of sense don't they
ribbond I'm sorry I did say they were
true Komori because we every now and
again we get one of the stations who who
has the potential to travel Juma and go
into the east and he came on the road
and he said is there any station can
they copy me and two times in the past
I've heard the same gentleman caller
they're ready just like that and they go
hello yes and he goes I've got hook
kumara crossing in from the West and
then we swarm over to exactly where we
are now and we find Herkimer so that's
why I interrupted my train of thought
and my discussion about lifelines with
James Richard and whoever else is the
lifeline out there and I interrupted my
train of thought there because who knows
could have been hooker Marie coming in
but he wanted an update because clearly
they can't find in the animals wherever
they are so they were trying to see if
void cell that was able to provide for
them which we do so often but we do
soften but it's 25 seconds we are going
to be turning into the road this is cheb
AMA Road Raja
just a little bit of a left and a right
to the chicane and we are approaching
the hyena den known okay everybody I'll
put you out of your misery it is indeed
the juma den there's lots of elephant
smells around here wonder if we going to
find anybody at home
hello if I knew that had a wooden door
we could knock you know but we don't
there's no wooden door someone there
it's one of the naughty ones well I'm
excited how do you Peter bye
hello and there is some I think your
Corky oh you know you might be Jude
are you happy Kreger someone here give
me a moment to try and identify them but
we've got to naughty ones on the top
there that's am already getting their
spots it's happening so quickly just
within a matter of a few days the spots
are starting to show and there's this
tune is it is June she's got a bit of a
cramp on her leg
he's been sitting to all hang out that's
definitely June she's decided she's
going to move her youngsters around a
little bit yes they come in closer
because mum said it's okay go play with
the funny-looking people I do apologize
about the poll in the bottom-left corner
okay well please go over to someone who
is watching an Impala yes we're watching
the Impala watching Columbo who's also
watching the Impala this is such a cool
shot though
faison's Rachel see now the big reveal
huh I'm pretty sure they know that she's
there though because they were very
suspicious about her when she arrived
she came prancing around I didn't even
get to take a picture of it on that
termite mound can you believe it but
this is really really awesome she sat
down now she obviously was standing up
she was quarter mid-walk and as the
Impala moves she sort of sat down a
little bit more and then Java she felt
comfortable that Impala wouldn't be able
to see her if she went right down now
this is where I personally think her
inexperience is going to show and I
think these kinds of things are very
interesting to watch she's very young
cat she's still small he should he's
probably been catching smaller meals
maybe the odd Impala lamb and a stand
book and daycares we're discussing but
for her to bring down a fully grown male
Impala there at the foetus that they're
going to be for the entire year that
would be impressive I'm not saying that
she cannot do it but it's definitely
going to be a big challenge but she's
this is kind of making it look like
Impala is not too far away
realistically she's about 60 meters 7
yeah but 60 meters or so away from that
Impala so she still got a lot of ground
to cover back
it's only getting better for her there's
a bit of a breeze the light is starting
to fade and if she's just patient those
Impala might be silly enough to hang
around here and maybe she'll go for them
right we're definitely going to stay
here and see how this plays out
Steve however has not put such a serious
sighting but rather one that'll make you
smile well you just in time everybody
that little smallest of the lot is
getting squashed yet by one of pretties
youngsters and mum has also been picking
her up and moving around by the foot
shame that's not a very nice life June
obviously being the lowest-ranking
female member feels the need to try and
discipline these youngsters what keeps
him in order in this individual let's
use the cutest individuals and the one
of pretties youngsters he has the one
with the et and the smiley face on the
side is the one who's gonna come right
up to the vehicle as always come and
smell my shoe I do apologize for the
polls we have no control over where the
hyenas move
little youngsters there with jr. so nice
to see the displays happening now so
you're all saying how cute their have
you all know it's just that quickly
those spots are starting to show on the
neck and upper body oh dude be nice be
nice they got to be tough to be ie near
any her to start tough with mum look at
that small they all compared to her she
is a decent sized female on let's say
that really has apologized that they're
all right at the back here but I mean if
we do start the car it's probably gonna
cause the youngsters to go running
inside and we don't want to do that
Sheehan is not going to be too bothered
in little et years and bothered either
wild isn't it the best high in a play
time I don't really know if it's plates
on when mums involved but definitely
when the other youngsters get involved
it is a really really fun sort of place
to be yep just in time what is it Tom
Craig it's about the right sort of time
of day isn't it yeah about six o'clock
there's a time of day when normally we
get to see these do these little ones
doing their thing doing an attendance
little furballs it's almost as if
because I saw Juden licking them very
vigorously last time so almost as if
that that brown or the dark fur gets
licked off of their shoulders for the
spots to start showing through
at least tooms is are looking a little
bit better
I noticed before just behind in the poll
of course but um they had lots of bite
marks on them the other day when I was
yet what have you seen their little one
as they are approaching something
approaching there could be benefit of
the dinners the hyenas have the
opportunity to quickly scamper to safety
if there's any danger it's always great
when you do find an adult in attendance
because then that means the anchors are
brave enough to come outside but I still
haven't seen corcyra Ana Corky pretty
around this den I've seen Corky a couple
of times cork is the one who actually we
found the den with she was here when
Okumura brought us here
and of course they're all going to go on
to the other side where we can't see
them kik-kik you want to know how far
away from Colombia I haven't heard it on
the radio but where they were this
morning apologized about how dirty this
old map is yet but we are over here on
shoe bomber wrote there and they're over
here some way so about two kilometers
one point five to two kilometers so
maybe just half a mile 700 you know just
under a mile not too far okay so a
little bit further than I just showed
that about double the distance a little
bit off not far actually another few
hundred meters from where I showed you I
don't think Colombia and these pain is
what really have anything of interest to
show each other it always at war sure I
said I'll only be interest smells and
sights and I wonder if she's ever seen a
small hyena before she's only ever been
plagued by the adults always come and
try and steal her food
Lauren Ilan slits you now they've just
moved back a bit see if we can get them
again
I haven't noticed if there's any
particular LARM call that they make but
they're just there's definitely a little
squeal that happens and then off they go
they just take off at the slightest
sound of any sort of an natural noise if
we even move the car or move my foots or
do something that's a little bit
unnatural for the youngsters they very
quickly turn and run for the den and
then quite often that they'll see that
mums still quite sort of relaxed and
then they'll stay so but as soon as she
disappears they are very jumpy when they
won't go very far yeah they will go much
further away from the den when she's in
when she's available she's around
otherwise they're quite skittish because
they know or should I say through
evolution of those cubs that have
strayed too far from a den do not
survive or those that have learned to
stay close it's imaginative makeup to do
so than to remain very close to the den
in the first few months the youngsters
at one there the et one a pretties
youngsters five six months now a little
bit more a little bit braver but they
don't venture more than 30 or 40 meters
away from the den they stay very very
close because they are still very very
at risk of predation and competition but
right now all these youngsters have to
worry about is mums jaws any once again
they've gone to the other side it's
nothing we can do about that everybody
they are going to they are wild animals
varying in mind and well as much as we
can they show some part of chicks from
time to time they still do whatever they
want to do in their own time and the
June is coming back up on the mound I
just moved back very small amount
okay well while we reposition let's go
back to Taylor mccurdy who I think might
have might be getting better views of
Columbo so Columbo is somewhere back
there can you still see her sensor so
she's she's either being very clever
she's realizes she's bitten off a bit
more than she can she she slunk towards
the corner wasn't I can have to do an
insta story of too slow and she's gone
round that way
boom hollow they're looking at her I
think the Impala nourish say that she's
yeah as they followed now we've stayed
still they've looked around that corner
just checking here because a grass is so
long yeah she just walked quite far off
all the way around the car and she went
down that side so we'll head in that
direction they've other stuff we hello
let's say you probably with the longer I
don't really see what's going on just go
back the way she went way away from them
oh she's going back to here we had her
this morning but now I've lost her
keep an eye on things also I'm gonna
focus yeah it's gonna make sure I can
pick it up again so now though you're so
small you can just hide away
don't hide away just take a quick moment
here to scan so she's gone into this
long grass over here it's gonna be hard
to see you I didn't want to move too
soon though I wanted to make sure that
she was completely out of sight before
we move so that the Impala couldn't see
what she was looking at huh can you see
how things
uh-huh okay let's check this termite
mound in front let's just see if she
hasn't just gone back to her mama
there's a real possibility that she just
went but big I'm a little bit small just
gave myself a fright I normally do no
she's not back here which means she must
have gone that way my llama you are
taking after your mother don't give us
the slipper risky now okay we'll reverse
obviously okay let's go and see
where'd you go hello mom where'd you go
let's take a wide berth try never get
all my goodness is a log and a half yeah
I'm gonna climb over it
are you ready sends all I have to first
get low arrange it it's not Minton hold
on sands oh I'm honored
oh can you see her okay then we'll go
around since I've spotted her when I was
trying to climb over the log there's
another termite mound around here so we
don't need to go over the log anymore
thank goodness where is it
so since you're sitting a lot higher
than I am he I can't even see the time
behind the wattle that one okay cool so
yeah I can't even see the timer mom but
it sounds like there's a trim up behind
behind this wattle grumpy old man oh
look how cool that can you see it
through that gap okay look at this I
want to show you something
so there she is sitting on a little
termite mound you can see how thick it
is yeah sorry grumpy old man yes she
definitely did learn her mom's trick she
covered that distance incredibly fast
but if she's set up like that I can't
imagine that the Impala would still be
around awesome okay before she moves
again I just wanted to show you cuz
that's a very cool little gap I love the
natural framing that we get from the
trees and branches and termites ones
yeah okay great we're gonna navigate to
towards her east we didn't do so well
done sins or eagle eyes off you go back
to Steve with all the hyena thanks
Taylor good luck there with the little
princess well hi you know I'm not
behaving very well mum has had to pick
up two of them individually and carry
them back to the tent and they just
follow out again he doesn't seem to have
the right technique Tandi always used to
basically give give that look that's
small and Columbo would just stop dead
in
Trax whereas here whereas yeah mom picks
them up drags them back by any appendage
she can hold on to and just chase it
back again I'm gonna go around that side
Craig see if we can get another view of
them because they they've got onto the
eastern wing of the den site which from
this side is very unviable having and
them playing around that side quite yet
it's always the first time this is their
world their home they need to learn
everything about this place for their
venture off out into the big bad wide
world here we go Robertson nothing that
I've seen you know I mean all sorts of
things can sort of cause them to change
the den being it's parasite loads or
even the presence of predators too many
times so like the real estate but I
don't know what it is that is the
initial order this whatever the call of
the Sun that's a nice is a gate today is
the time to change it might be once the
youngsters at a certain sort of size
that they can either walk or be carried
at really don't know obviously she would
to be easy if they could just follow her
to new den and maybe that's why she's
picking them up so many times now maybe
she's getting ready to try and take them
somewhere near you and whether that
would be her decision or Corky's is very
hard to sell I don't know I'll be honest
and tell you that I and put my hands up
in the air there and say I'm not sure
but these youngsters are very very
encouraged to our mums around and they
are definitely veering a lot further
away than I've seen them do so okay mum
there we go nudge the back on to the
other side where we've come from very
good another one about to come out of
the bushes there we go very excited very
happy to be around and mum sets even
wagging his tail her happy hyenas
cuteness overload just smelling
absolutely everything when we came into
the sighting we came in where are they
where they're walking now and I said I
could smell strong smells of elephants
and well that's probably they're going
at whoa what is this thing can we eat it
and well if you asked Sydney Taylor and
Ollie they'll all say yes you can't eat
it there Marilla fruits inside anyway
you get mum's gonna go see there's a
facial expression there we go you're
learning you're learning up see that
it's not listening I think they're just
called spots really the difference in
leopard in that cheetah is we we sell a
piece of got rosettes and sheets have
got spots where the spotted hyena is a
spotted hyena also known as the laughing
hyena I don't know maybe there's a a
blotchy high you know or something you
do get the striped hyena and the spotted
hyena so that makes it quite easy to
identify the difference okay Craig er
looks like we're going back to the
western side they are definitely making
us work for this today that's all right
we don't mind we don't mind giving June
a hard time she's stuck once again with
all the parental duties and I think the
youngsters have been suckling because
they're running around like they've had
a belly full of milk and they're being
very naughty per month and I'm sure
she's going to just now put them in the
den and then walk off to go in search of
some food for herself because there's
only so much you can do with the kids
isn't they when they start annoying you
then you just have to put your foot down
okay this one's well behaved today
without its sibling very well behaved
you can see the et on the side there can
you see that thanks to Michael Fleetwood
for helping me with your identification
now I'll never forget it is eet just on
the lower back and then on this the
other side it's got really weird lying
spots
this is the naughty one this is the one
that no is I'm trying to remember I
think it's the other one
I only got the end of that Craig
something Chris rogue said Oh Chris
Traeger if it's your birthday we wish
you a very very happy birthday
here we go this is Chris rogue happy
happy birthday to you
well the arena's are here for you today
and we can add we could find them for
you there we go they're gonna fall in
the hole and June is going to give me a
little look and say why are you parking
yeah and it is indeed Jaime Patterson's
birthday today as well as different to
the Buddha's birthday so happy birthday
to everyone Arthur who's turning however
old you're turning on the 3rd of March
this lovely 2019 well we are surrounded
now by hyenas and I am in a position oh
don't be scared
there we go she's hurting them hurting
them sorry but my head hurting them it's
getting to that time normally about half
past 6:00 when they're sort of the bell
goes and the youngsters all have to move
in to the den and it's interesting to
see an adult so active around a den like
this it's definitely giving me the
little evil eye there okay - now I'm
going to reposition myself so that I'm
not giving you any sort of giving you
space these youngsters are very closest
see how they respond when the vehicle
starts and I'm gonna give it I'm gonna
give it a moment let them smell us hello
little guys close they are yet sorry
buddy you're good to see how close they
are and how relaxed that do become and
that's all habituation due to the fact
that the adults are relaxed to us if the
adults were not relaxed it would be a
different story you know you see they're
looking around going where's mum where
did she go she walked behind a car
hello little one
rfat as far as I'm aware hyenas are
born with teeth and they're the only
mammals our nerve that do so so I think
that teeth just keep growing I don't
think I eNOS have got milk teeth like
other animals I do stand to be corrected
but as far as I've been come to
understand the late that they're born
with them and they grow with them and
they sort of fill out as they get older
so very interesting strategy and I think
quite unique to hyena but I do stand to
be corrected there I do know that
they're the only sort of mammal that
I've ever heard of that's actually born
with teeth already erupted which is very
very unique and that's obviously to bite
straight out of the room very feisty
little animals I think as their mouth
grows the teeth grow with them
whoa hey that's my foot any little
naughtiness this is defi the naughty one
that likes to smell my shoe if you might
have heard a little bit of a bang that
was it knocking its nose on the panel
next to my foot
Jamie is going to be very pleased when
she comes back that we've got the juma
den here
I sent her a few photos today of these
naughty little hyenas for her birthday
to say the hyenas send their regards
behind the car you go so a lot of you
been asking when Jamie's back I believe
she is arriving back on Tuesday with
Tristan Dix himself I thought he was
coming back a little bit later but he's
back from India soon and I think he's
back on Tuesday don't hold me to that I
think that there might be some
difficulties in his flight but I do
believe he's coming back on Tuesday how
cute is that
what happened - what happened - MS
chasing something there's another hyena
coming in there's another hyena coming
in that tuners decided I don't want you
here hyena
let's go see if we can see who it is she
lifted a tail you heard those squeals
didn't you as the iron off to the left
you heard those squeals sorry about the
roof everybody he has the other one over
here Craig oh let's see who is that so
June's posture changed and she started
running away from the den all the pups
all the Cubs sorry I keep saying it
they've altered - for the den and they
went in now I can't see any
characteristic spots or tears on the
ears so who it is I don't know I'm sure
we'll know in a minute but the one young
step is on its way to go and say hello
so I don't think it's a threat to the
dead well it's just that the shocked
appearance of someone coming in and
let's see what happens here the one
youngsters about to approach a beautiful
pink light coming through the clouds now
now our thought Juden was the only Juma
clan female to have no markings or
proper markings on the ears if I
remember heart has got a gouge Corki
pretty I've got gouges so who is this
I'm missing a name am I not I am missing
a name anyway if any of you can identify
that individual that is on the shot Oh
Ruben is the other one and Ruben has got
two very characteristic lines on the
side you see the youngster on the right
was busy pasting that sort of hyena
behavior where they take their anal
gland and they secrete a paste onto some
vegetation something that youngsters
practice and do a lot around the den
something the adults do away from the
dinner as a form of territory
in the bush okay well we're going to try
and figure out who you this individual
is no idea at the moment seemingly not a
threat at all to the youngsters so while
we try and figure out exactly who this
is
we're gonna go that two kilometers are
set to the east to Taylor with the
princess Columba look at all the beauty
that is in the shot the most gorgeous
elephant motive you've ever laid eyes on
and then there's also Columba who has
now got a halo over her isn't that
gorgeous
I should also be taking photos of her
because I could get very nice backlit
shots but the people come first all of
you watching I will not click away just
because I will just now and I'm gonna
use it not opportunity to take an
illegal photo earlier but also look how
gorgeous this is I think this is a
picture perfect shot to to showcase Juma
with Jackson and all his guests are
jackal berry and a beautiful south
african sunset with all those colors it
is totally gorgeous hayseeds wiper kind
of take a picture together
everyone ready oh no gotta gotta open
the phone there this is what I should be
photographing now for Instagram that
nice sensor is it the same shall we
compare we're going to show you I have
to bring mine closer look no no this is
that beautiful I'll need some work love
a little edit hey sensor since this is
much better of course he's a
professional I just sometimes pretend
that I can take pictures
these are hope you got some screenshots
of Maurice and calamba if you didn't
have to go back and stop watching right
so that you can get screenshots and
hashtags fire lab and share them because
I need to put them on the sub at safari
live officials Facebook page and so is
this where we took the car over
do apologize about any technical issues
then if you maybe saw the roof or the
sky whose crank is busy putting on the
infrared light as it is getting to that
time of day so I'm gonna move over just
a touch over here we don't know who that
hyena is there but there is some
beautiful skies on our art hand side
coming through with obviously hyenas as
well so let me put you there you happy
crack beautiful pink of the evening you
thought it might rain
I certainly put on the roof but just to
be careful put the roof on and now here
we are in the beautiful beautiful
afternoon there's very humid today said
had the feeling rain was on the way but
well if anything humidity is only
embolden to these youngsters who just
before you came back to us Jun head
around the neck and I was throwing back
towards the din she's gonna go back to
who that evidence of the hyena is I
still haven't managed to identify his
rolling around in something on the
ground but while we put on our IR lights
and let's go back up to Patrick
Fitzgerald in the Maasai Mara
well everyone we have found ourselves a
civet here hiding in the bushes so it
was on the path before and it's just
jumped off and we can just see eyes
there now we are in infrared which is
why everything look is looking a little
bit black and white now and sorry this
is a sir boom
sorry no they say that they serve what a
beautiful little cat live is still a
part of the family the Felidae
viewing us very curiously there now we
actually have a really great so I think
of one of these on foot it was a
training drive with Lauren and James and
I and he'd show he just wanted to show
us how the actor and elephants on foot
and everything and as we were walking
back he stopped to show us a little
mound where there was some scat from one
of these little cats and then we heard
something rustling in the bushes right
next to us and would you know it jumped
one of these it was absolutely amazing
to see on foot and apparently very rare
as well
and now giraffe go don't worry I was on
the way we have found the giraffes we
just had to make a bit of a loop because
our off road and we couldn't quite see
them in range well obviously we were
using infrared so we just couldn't quite
get them so I've come around and we're
just coming up to the trees that they
were hiding away and that was about ten
of them but of course we have to stop
for this cutie
they do kind of resemble a very small
leopard at time Daniel they do they have
very large eyes and there is a reason
for this they are obviously nocturnal
animals so you will see them more often
out and about at night time and this
obviously means that they have to be
able to see better at night as well
those big eyes and then also above the
eyes you can see they have massive ears
as well probably hearing every word I'm
saying right now
very good senses very good hunters as
well
it's around watching us from the bushes
as I said it was right on the road as
well not the road that the path that we
were taking everyone saying that they're
loving the background sounds as low and
yes I love it too the nighttime here is
a very peaceful time apart from the
occasional even not once you get over
the eeriness of the working of the
hyenas it's actually quite a soothing
sound
all right well yeah keep on pressing on
up the road here the giraffes shouldn't
be too far away how good was that though
lucky me so this has kind of made all
the bad luck I've had today kind of turn
around and so if we can get these
giraffes before the end of the drive
well I might go home a bit of a happier
man and what I thought so oh now we had
that nice little cat so I think it lets
it go to Taylor who has a little bit of
a bigger cat
what did you say about me no joking haha
just drugs but young tell them I think
she was gonna come for a drink but she's
surprised as a person who is on
sundowners then she got a little bit
nervous of them so here she is
ah drink the water the water so we can
all please so you should be able to see
your art a your going what you want me
to go around
photographers we're just gonna take a
little look we're not gonna get as great
of a shot I'm afraid but it's okay we're
late the photographers have this one I
want to terrify that's better not ideal
but it's okay hey she is she's having
drink water so no you can see her face
is illuminated quite a bit um since a
week can we get Kirsten can we go into
color is that okay because there is
another vehicle here with us and they
are using a spotlight so we might as
well if we can maybe just staying kind
of those are gonna get very overexposed
okay we in color now everybody cousin
speaking in her nasally voice again her
normal voice so she's just having a
drink and this is pretty epic for the
photographers this is pretty much what
they would have wanted so there are
different types of safaris that you can
go on and this is a this is specifically
for photographic purposes so they want
big cats typically they want all things
beautiful deeps Debbie Debra he said
this is beautiful can you listen to the
sounds listen to the hyena I'm gonna
take a photo there sorry buzz
me stood up as usual I can take very
good pictures I run my you know that's
mink I should go to was a real high
either in the card wasn't it was just me
I know I'm known for my animal cool said
no one ever
okay I'm gonna stop spotting I'm gonna
find naughty spot I'm not gonna put too
much light on her she's fine though
she's not really hunting she's just on
the move she's going from point A to B
you know so she's not stopped and she's
changed her actually get chance to walk
on the animal pathway should we watch
her for a bit ditzy
she goes no she'll disappear behind the
quarry she going back to the mall righty
so she just came out for a little drink
of water so we gonna pop down here okay
perfect she gon we gon hyenas are not
gone so you can go and have a look at
them and I wonder if those are the ones
are just heard calling all the
youngsters are out now on the other side
of the road
well not direct from the vehicle from us
and I haven't seen that other hyena
again but I'm going to assume it was
Ruben because I don't think it the
proper look at it but I didn't notice
any sort of really big sort of cuts out
of the ears but I couldn't really have
seen the left front you clearly know
Ruben does have a little bit of a mark
on her left yet but she has a
materialize to get so I wonder if it is
indeed hurt it's definitely I mean ax
that there no it was quite a big one as
well so Ruben definitely is higher in
their ranking and in Juden is and she
was just towards the back there moment
to go and haven't seen her since we've
heard some marinas are walking in the
distance
normally the calling courts bring them
all together crisp and crystal thought
it might have been the mail okay I stand
to be corrected I didn't really get a
good enough look I thought by the size
it was a female but I do not know I'm
not hundred percent sure but they're all
behind me now very difficult for me to
move unfortunately everybody okay now I
can move there we go here they come
again
June's gonna bring them back to the den
and there we go three two one bedtime
Daniel a good question
I'm not really sure how good it is I did
think it's much better than ours hey
this is my foot you're gonna come to my
foot again so I think it's far better
than ours but like other predators they
see in black and white but I think a lot
of it is movement that they detect they
don't really have the necessary ability
for depth perception but I think they
our site is pretty decent and obviously
they can see in the dark which we can't
so I'd say they've got far better
eyesight than we do but they lack the
depth perception that color vision
provides but on a scale of one to ten I
really couldn't tell you how great the
asset is their nose and hearing is
phenomenal so you'd think that our site
is also quite well adapted if Bailey
keeps him safe
eyesight allows us to see and detect
lions and all sorts of things that might
be trying to sort of hunt them down but
then there will also probably hunt a lot
by a sound and by smell but then
eyesight is pretty okay but I don't
think it's below average of these
probably above average okay well we are
surrounded once again that don't where
are you going little one don't quite
know where to go right now we kind of
hemmed in here with a bush in front and
all the youngsters playing behind us and
unfortunates making for some very
awkward camera work from Craig I do
apologize Craig had to apologize to all
of the viewers back home and that we
keep getting these poles in the way we
are in the infrared as you know and it
does reflect back against anything close
by which when there's bushes in the way
or a pole or the roof
then it makes it tricky hello Janet you
want to know when these little girls
will start eating meat not sooner than
eight months maybe even more than that
but considering that they are the lowest
ranking females offspring they're going
to have to start following her sooner
than the likes of plonk would so seven
eight nine months or so they'll start
venturing away from the den with June to
go and feed on carcasses or meat out
there because if June brings anything
back being a low-ranking female well she
will be all her Cubs will be the last
ones to eat it being the matrix office
Britain plunk will have a better sort of
Rights and if the korky does bring
anything back well then it's very likely
that she will allow him to eat no one
else will but these dynamics they can
shift they can't change who knows what
will be happening by the time these
youngsters reach eight nine months he
might be an entire shift in the
hierarchy here all we can do is sit and
watch I still haven't yet seen any
proper sort of hyena into action of
individuals females coming together and
showing the submissive display he and
rumor we saw a fair bit of it in the
Mara but maybe here cuz the clans are so
much smaller a lot of that happens maybe
less frequently maybe up in the morrow
there's so many more individuals has to
happen more frequently I don't I don't
know but for now
and there we go the two of them are out
there by the halt get another view of
vent before I think they're about to go
down for the night it is getting past
their bedtime nope
straight back are to get there it is too
cute aren't they there's the light
source I think up inna the den site with
him up
well they found a stick that stick is in
serious trouble that stick is in serious
trouble there we go this well I was
watching before when you were new away
from us and one of the youngsters is
definitely the the less dominant because
not only was it sibling giving it a
beating mom was coming and picking the
sides of the one that was to get the
beating and actually picking it up out
of the back leg and dropping it on the
floor while the other one was having at
his neck in its ear so it's not very
nice if you you think you've got a fair
game against someone of your own size
and then mum comes along and tips the
odds in the favor of the other one maybe
she's got a favorite okay well okay
there's lots of energy here around the
gym again I do apologize once again
about all the metal in the way Lauren I
don't know where plonk all the other one
of pretties youngsters are plunks being
here most of the times I've come through
there really is quite strange I mean
pretty I haven't seen Oh has anyone seen
pretty I think she was seen around here
or crab cabs a yeah they're not they're
not dead and they're not Amman ceated so
he's probably um maybe he's having a bit
of a sleep inside the den maybe he
thought it was gonna rain we slept in
maybe he's having a a movie session with
the other youngster inside they're just
all just cuddled waiting waiting for for
the night to come out maybe the female
but brave they're gonna have a an
all-nighter I really have no idea but
okay you're surrounded once again June
is sitting there lastly in the open
you'd think that maybe the youngsters
wanted to suckle but they don't do they
keep running it's a game of ping pong
tennis I don't know where to look as
soon as you look left
the youngsters run rats as soon as we
look rot they'll run left bearing in
mind never run this is live and they
have no control of these animals they
come and go as they please
okay well it's probably going to be time
for these ones to go to bed and for June
to go out on her nightly forage but
while we see what happens let's go back
over to Taylor I believe she's left
lumber let's go see what her plans are
wonderful sounds like you've had a
fantastic afternoon watching those hyena
I have to still go and visit them I
haven't even been there perhaps I shall
go there tomorrow yes that is exactly
what I'll be doing oh that's a bit but
wait they didn't know we just drove
through a puddle until I heard it so I'm
driving very slowly because I'm
determined to find a chameleon as I
don't know Kirsten has anybody seen a
Charmeleon the the CIA because I feel
like this time last year we were seeing
loads they were everywhere well I think
I came back and beginning a March
of course how could I forget of course
if anyone was going to see a comedian
was going to be Madame Queen of Africa
Amy Patterson whose birthday it is today
if you have not wished Jamie Patterson a
happy birthday I can't talk to interview
ever again you're not in my life so
you're all gonna have to go and wish a
non-spam her Oh nope nope nope nope nope
is it a Kirsten on a morning Safari not
only that that's because I was new and
inexperienced and I panicked and I
thought I used to have to listen to
Kirsten all the time so she was the boss
I realized since then and Kirsten Sogeti
sing a song for Steve and Jamie cuz this
was a States birthday and and then I did
a rap do you guys remember that I think
I shared it on Facebook to them I can't
I really wish Jamie happy good that I
just shared the same video from last
year and then she can listen to it again
she can listen to me rapping terribly
I'm not singing I'm too old for that now
I'm in my late thirties have to be an
adult now what Hey please Kirsten I
didn't hear you you're you are cackling
she was laughing it I'm not gonna stand
here
what did you say guys
she's cousin says ah so funny she says
this like it's a threat to me she says
I'll stay with you for the next eight
minutes until I sing girl bring it
silence Sally overhears not saying a
word
it's just beautiful
Oh supposed to do my point wait since I
can't you know what can you come back to
me like that I want to try something out
are you ready it's a dance movement okay
I'm gonna do the mix can wave and then
I'm gonna point there okay you ready for
this okay one two I'm gonna do that for
you and from now on when I see something
amazing how does that sound good
do you like that move do you think if I
use that move in the club I'll be
popular since I was now nodding what do
you think should we do a poll Kirsten if
I did that move and point it at a man Oh
Jake I'm only joking you probably run
for the hills but I think that's quite a
cool movement but it's very pretty
the lights are starting to fade now do
you think so I could bring the old moves
how do you even do the sprinkler I don't
know since I how'd you do the sprinkler
I can't do the sprinkler that's so sure
old school moves
um right I what I was doing something I
had a spotlight in my hand and I was not
toiling my hair was looking for it
comedian Kirsten I can't say what not it
used to be anymore
I've grown I'm an adult now but you mean
when you spell adults the way you said
you spell it CH il Divo
yeah
so I'm not gonna sing you can stay with
me till tomorrow maybe I'll sing it in
my sleep though til tomorrow morning
I'll go someone bring me dinner that's
fine
finally she has given up right off you
go to pet to the Mara he's failed at
doing something out but potentially he
could redeem himself by singing Stephan
James not James Stephan Cheney more bad
luck so we were right there close to the
giraffes and the path was just so muddy
that we had to punch through this really
bad bit and I think the engine obviously
got a little bit loud and it just starts
with them and they just kept running and
running and obviously no I was just
saying that if I can redeem myself if I
sing a song maybe maybe but back who I
say so they yeah they you just ran off
and we tried to catch up to him but
there's such high alert at nighttime
because of all the Predators are out
especially lions so they're really kept
on their toes at night and I think we
started them now Emma what was it that
Taylor said that she wanted me to sing a
song about
I mean catch that last bit apparently I
need to sing a song but I'm not sure
what about
Jamie and said Steph a song about Jamie
and Steph oh it's that birthday Oh happy
birthday to you happy birthday to you
happy birthday dear Jamie instead happy
birthday to you as you can see I'm a
well-trained singer with immense vocal
range
I hope that redeems the lack of sure
haha
oh wait well forgot something if it
alright if it alright if it's alright
[Music]
I'll be here oh wait guys okay
all right Taylor well I held up my end
of the bargain now I think it's time
that you do a little bit of singing
yourself as well
no Patrick that does not count does Pat
stand for Patrick well Patricia I'm not
sure so Kirsten agrees it's is it stands
for Patricia
you can't just sing the original happy
birthday that is not the wild earth way
how come I had to do a rap oh it's
because Brian was gonna cause me and he
could beat box and then we all said it
was great we had some tinging like there
was lots of things going I think I was
bearing banging a quarry branch as all
the side effects I can't
I'm uninspired I saying so can sing
since or on a sing happy birthday
censuses is to justify using my excuse
get your own synthesis is true I'm too
old you can go since overseeing a unique
version of happy birthday
and yes in your opera please and we're
waiting since I'll do it with you I
promise but would you do it if I did how
did his upper go
[Music]
Jamie
we literally hear crickets well-kept for
ourselves in so I don't know I don't
know where those people came from but
anyways that is my supposed that it is
how you're supposed to be singing happy
birthday that how are you supposed to be
singing happy birthday that is not how
you supposed to speak English though
that's for sure since I can sing really
well you all know that I can't sing and
I just do it because i annoy people and
when people tell me she shouldn't sing
it you can't sing very well then I'm
gonna sing even more proponents tell me
I can't do things yep yeah no I'm not
not surprised that there was no mention
of me there well dancing so that was
superb I don't know what you're doing
here and filming I think you should be
doing all sorts of other things
oh goodness it's almost the end of the
show now I feel like they cut it short
just because of skipper they're like
well making it these two off camera
anyways it was lots of fun I was nice to
her too leopards good to see kochava
again she's alive and doing well of
course always lovely to see the little
princess Columba died eanes bouncing
about as they normally are Steve talking
about butterflies and their mating and
Patricia back in the Mara and he's got
an ear outfit he's got sugars he's
learning the Masai way so big thank you
from one of us here at wild earth we'll
be doing it again bright and early see
you then
[Music]
you